- It's time for dinner!
- Back in my day, people
talked face to face!
- Ass to ass!
(soft music)
- All right, Joey, do the intro.
- All right, hello, my
bass boosted brethren.
Welcome to another episode of Trash Taste.
- Oh, that was-
- That one sounded so sad.
What the fuck?
- That was an old school
Joey intro.
- I know!
I'm bringing back the alliteration.
- [Garnt] For one episode!
- Even though that was
not alliterated at all.
- You sounded so depressed, though.
You sounded so depressed.
- Okay, Mudan let's do this again.
Mudan, base boost me when I say this.
Welcome back my bass
boosted brethren brothers!
Welcome back to another
episode of Trash Taste podcast.
I'm bass boosted boy number one,
with bass boosted boy
number two and three.
- Hello.
- Hi.
- My permanent life is bass boost.
- Yeah, that's what I was going to say,
that's just your voice, isn't it?
- It never got turned off.
It just got left on.
- Put up the treble on
Connor, like, really high.
How you boys been?
- We're good.
- We're all tired as fuck.
- Oh my...
- What?
- "How are you doing?"
- What, am I not allowed
to ask how your day's been?
- I just kinda wish you'd asked me
with a little more enthusiasm.
- How you guys doing?
How was your weekend?
- How have you been Connor?
- How have you been?
- How have you been? I'll be
a therapist for this week.
- Thank you, Joey. I appreciate it.
- [Joey] How are you feeling?
- I feel like you need a therapist, Joey.
'Cause I feel like you've
almost been canceled again
on Twitter for saying more hot takes.
- Is this gonna be the weekly thing
or it's just like review
possible cancellations?
- [Joey] Cancellation of the week.
- Cancellation of the week!
- And today, on the chopping block today!
- I just found it funny
that after all this time
you actually go out your
way to watch Anime again.
- The one time I tweet about Anime,
and I almost get canceled.
- Joey has the first Anime
take in what, like, six months?
- What was the take?
- The take- (laughs)
- [Connor] Remind me.
- Okay.
So let me bring you up to speed, right?
Because this is a multi-layered thing.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- This is like a multi-layered meme.
- Multiple angles to cancel.
- Okay, so it started off,
the layer first starts at
the Kson episode, right?
Which pictures of us recording,
it just went up, right?
Thankfully, a lot of people loved it.
It was a great episode, right?
But on one segment of that show,
and there's a highlight clip of it,
is where we talk about the
"Jujutsu Kaisen" Anime.
I think it's because
we were talking to Kson
about what Anime she's watched recently
or something like that.
- Yeah.
Right, right.
- It was weeks ago for us.
And so I was like, after
me finally having seen it
a while back, I was like,
"Oh, I think this might be
a perfect time right now,
since we're already
talking about the Anime,
to kind of go into it a little
bit, talk about it, right?"
Give our thoughts on it.
Our hot takes, if you will.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And my hot take of "Jujutsu
Kaisen" was me saying,
"I thought it was okay."
(Connor and Garnt giggling)
And then followed by, "I
just prefer "Demon Slayer"."
As an show, right?
And there's a fucking highlight clip.
- I mean, you are clown for that opinion.
I gotta admit, right?
Maybe, I don't know, the new
season though is kind of tough.
- [Joey] Right.
- Okay, at the time of recording though,
that was a clown take,
but now, okay, maybe not.
- I mean, was it clown take though?
Because it's literally...
'Cause in the clip, I'm
pretty sure I said something
along the lines of, "Jujutsu
Kaisen" had everything that
I thought I was going to like."
But for some reason, whatever it was,
I can't even give a proper,
viable reason for it
to just say that for some reason,
it just didn't really click in my head.
Never did I say that the show was like mid
or that the show was bad in any way.
I just said, "I thought it was okay."
Twitter went ballistic over that.
And there were a couple of videos-
- How ballistic are we talking?
Just a few angry people or?
- I mean, Twitter does what
Twitter does best, right?
Just over blows everything
outta proportion,
but I even had a couple
of people tweeting at me
videos from small AniTubers being like,
"Joey, you're getting canceled."
And I'm like, "Oh, God, what now?
Is it for something I liked
on Twitter? I don't know."
And I went to look at it and it was like,
"Joey's hottest take on "Jujutsu Kaisen"."
And on the thumbnail, it just says,
"He thought it was okay."
And I was like, "Oh, my God!"
I can't even call a show okay anymore
without being canceled!
Like, what the fuck is this?
So that's layer one, all right?
- Okay.
- Layer two is when I started watching
"Demon Slayer" season two recently, right?
And I made a tweet, first tweet
in six months about Anime,
where I said something along the lines of,
Started watching season
two of "Demon Slayer"
happy to say Zenitsu is still
the worst character in the show.
All the Zenitsu fans
went ballistic, you know?
As they do.
- Of course they do.
- As they do, calling him
best boy and whatever.
- [Connor] They stand up,
wearing those diapers...
- Yeah, exactly.
Just pooping violently with rage.
"How dare you-"
(imitating sharting noises)
You know?
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
But then some people took it back
to that recent fucking clip
of me talking about "Jujutsu Kaisen",
saying that "Demon Slayer" is
better than "Jujutsu Kaisen."
And they had the audacity to be like,
"Oh, now he's backpedaling!
Now he's backpedaling!
He hyped up "Demon Slayer" so much,
even comparing it to "Jujutsu Kaisen",
saying it was better
than "Jujutsu Kaisen",
and now he's saying that 'Demon
Slayer' is not a good show."
Which I never said, mind you.
I just said Zenitsu fucking
sucks because he does. Right?
- Yeah, he does.
- And it's like, if anything,
I'm fucking enjoying season two right now.
Season two's been great.
I feel season two's kind of brought back
the hype for "Demon Slayer"
for a lot of people, right?
- I wasn't that hyped,
but season two has made
me definitely hyped.
- Like the like movie, as...
Oh, God, is this gonna be
another fucking hot take?
As okay as I thought the movie was.
(all laughing)
- No, okay, okay, I'll agree with you.
I thought that season two
has blown the movie out of the water.
- Do you know what? I'm gonna say.
Because I recently just finished
my Anime of the year video,
I feel like Anime has
gotten so much better now
that just saying something is okay
is now detrimental to the Anime.
- Right.
- Right?
It's not even bad anymore.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Calling something mid is an insult
and calling something okay is an insult.
- I feel like it's a copy paste now,
where everyone is like,
"'Attack on Titan' is mid."
It's basically a copy paste.
Everyone that keeps
saying that exact phrase.
No elaboration.
"Attack on Titan is mid."
- Because it's such easy bait.
- Yeah, it is!
It's literally bait, but everyone does it.
- But the thing is, I didn't even say
"Jujutsu Kaisen" is okay for bait.
I just legitimately think it's just okay.
(all laughing)
- I really like "Jujutsu Kaisen".
- And that's fine, right?
There were parts of "Jujutsu
Kaisen" I really enjoyed,
but I personally didn't enjoy
it as much as other people
or as I thought I was going to.
- Well, do you feel like
saying something is okay or mid
is even more of an insult
than saying something is bad nowadays?
'Cause I feel like-
- [Joey] Maybe.
- I feel like I've just, at
least in discussing shows
or Anime or whatever, or Manga,
I feel like you don't see as many people
just saying something is
straight up bad anymore.
People just say, "Oh,
it's mid. It's just mid."
- Yeah, okay, I get the word mid.
- Mid is insulting.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause mid is so little effort
to articulate how you feel about a show
that you can't even get the energy
to even describe what
you don't like about it.
It's so annoying.
- I feel like the word average
when talking about a show,
there's like a contention between
okay being taken more in a positive way,
and then mid being taken
in a negative way, right?
But they both mean the same
thing, technically speaking.
Mid is just short for middle!
Which is okay!
Neither good or bad, just okay, right?
But I feel now people take the word okay
and put a negative spin
on it, which I don't-
- I get it. I get it.
It's like, let's say you
had a wedding, right?
- Yeah.
- And you're like,
"Mom, did you like the wedding?"
She's like, "It was okay."
- I would be annoyed.
I would be like, "What do you
mean my wedding was just okay?
I invited you I put on a
spread! You said it's okay?
The bar was free!"
- But I feel it's kind
of on you to compare
your own wedding to "Jujutsu Kaisen".
(all laughing)
- I was gonna say!
- That's, how strongly I feel
about my best friend, okay!
- I was like, "How do we
get from "Jujutsu Kaisen"
to a wedding?"
- I'm just thinking, let's
just say you pour your heart
and soul out into something you like.
"Eh, it's okay."
(all laughing)
- I'm gonna go to Sydney
today and be like,
"Sydney, I know we're
getting married this year,
but like just "Jujutsu Kaisen", right?
I mean, it's kind of more
important than the wedding.
I pour my heart into "Jujutsu Kaisen"
more than I did the
wedding and the planning."
- [Joey] You know that
there are people out there
that would say that.
- I hope somebody asked me,
"How was Garnt's wedding?"
'Cause I know what I'm gonna say.
I already know what I'm gonna say.
- "I preferred "Jujutsu Kaisen" over it."
- Yeah, "I wish I could've
watched the new season."
- "I feel like he poured his
heart more into "Demon Slayer".
Honestly, he is more
passionate about that."
- Yeah, I don't know.
So my advice to all of you
who perhaps want to share
your opinion about Anime,
don't use the word okay from now on.
It can get you canceled.
- No, it's just 'cause
of who we are, right?
It's 'cause now we have this little show,
we do this little thing.
- This little show, yeah.
- This little show.
- And I think there's
a lot more eyes on us,
so people wanna get angry at what we say.
'Cause a lot of the times the people
who get annoyed at this stuff,
aren't the people who
actually watch Trash Taste.
There's people outside of Trash Taste
who maybe have some followers
who've watched Trash Taste.
Maybe seen some of the clips
or whatever and they're like,
"You won't believe what these guys
who I don't already watch
or engage with said."
They don't know how we behave
or how we go towards a
topic or how we tackle it.
It's just like, he just said this thing.
I disagree with it. I'm gonna get angry.
- What's really weird,
especially about my
"Jujutsu Kaisen" hot take,
"hot take", is the fact that
I called "Jujutsu Kaisen" okay
months ago on my own channel.
No one fucking batted an eye.
I say it on Trash Taste,
everyone loses their minds.
- I think 'cause it's Trash Taste, right?
It's weird, 'cause I feel
we've got to that point now
where not super small Twitter accounts,
but some Twitter accounts
with some decent followings
will be like, "This clown
take on Trash Taste XXX."
But I think that's also kind of cool.
I'm like, "Oh, that's
awesome that people feel like
we're big enough where they
could just openly criticize us."
I'm like, "Go ahead, man!"
- It is humbling to think
that my offhand comment
about an Anime has stirred
up this much controversy.
I mean, it's kinda cool, but
at the same time, it's like,
can you not cancel me for
saying that a show is okay?
I could candidly sleep over it if somebody
gets angry at me on Twitter.
- Oh, I not sleeping over it.
I think it's a little like, you know.
- I'm glad.
Imagine back four or five years ago
if I'd said the same shit,
no one would give a fuck.
- No one would care.
- I'm glad that people care!
Sometimes it's annoying.
- It's a little too much.
- But I love it.
- Thank you for caring about
my dumb opinion about a show.
- I don't care about Joey's
opinion, so you shouldn't!
- I don't even care about my opinion!
I just said it!
- Well, I think the argument
is that we are creators
who have a platform and an influence.
I mean, that's why they
call people like us
influencers, right?
(Joey retching)
Even though we fucking hate the word.
- I'm allergic to that word.
- I love it, actually.
I've got that evil voice going for me,
so I feel like it works
when someone calls me
an influencer, you know?
- It's just the one thing I
don't like about out that word
is that it can apply to
so many things, you know?
A cult leader is technically
an influencer as well.
- [Garnt] Those are the OG influencers.
- They're the OG influencers, right?
I don't know if I wanna be bunched up
in those kinds of people.
- I'm kidding, by the way.
I don't actually like the word.
I like to think that I make something
that's somewhat entertaining and good.
- Yeah, I'm just a dude on the internet.
- [Connor] I don't know, yeah.
- With a bunch of hot takes.
- I get it to a certain extent,
where we do have to be careful about
some of the stuff we say
'cause there are some topics that I feel
we do have to navigate very carefully.
- [Joey] Of course.
- Because there are
other creators out there
who do have a platform, and their words,
they say shit and their
words have a tangible effect
on the real world and the
community they talk to,
but at the same time,
there are some things that
blows my mind that people
care this much about, right?
And one of the biggest things
that I don't understand is
people will take this one
minute, two minute clip
from Trash Taste or
from one of our streams.
'Cause this happened to me
a bunch of times, right?
Where I will see this
clip being circulated.
where it's a one or two minute clip
from the podcast or my
stream that's not scripted,
it's just in a conversation
that's most of the time
doesn't even have anything to do
with the take that I'm
saying in that one clip
because it's one or two minutes.
And they will take this clip
and then spin it to a whole new level of-
- I get it, like you've
planned it all out.
- Yeah!
- It's a fucking mastermind move.
- And I think of this in context, right?
And I'm thinking, I don't
think people who watch our show
or people who are super fans of the show
is going to be influenced
by a one minute clip
of us talking about this one subject
that most of the time doesn't even
have to do with the overall conversation,
it's just most of the time
just an offhand comment something.
I don't think that's gonna
fucking influence anybody.
- But on that segment, Joey,
where you spoke about "Jujutsu
Kaisen" and I was like,
"No, you're a clown. It's good."
If you're a viewer, it's like,
how can you argue that you are
being influenced to be like,
"Jujutsu Kaisen" is mid or okay."
'Cause there's an active argument going on
where we're saying, "No,
it's not. You're wrong."
So as the viewer, what would
you take away from that?
It's not, "Oh, I'm gonna think
"Jujutsu Kaisen" is mid."
Even if you're a super fan.
It's so stupid.
- But that's what I think I like about
those kinds of discussions on the show,
especially when two or all of us
are arguing against each other, right?
Is that it gives so many
different points of views,
where it's up to the viewers now
who you want to agree with, right?
And it's not so much me saying,
"Hey, because I think
"Jujutsu Kaisen" is okay,
you should also think that way."
I mean, if you want to think
that way that's on you, right?
But it's not like I'm coming out here
fucking starting a demo of being like,
"Everybody, stand up and rise!
"Jujutsu Kaisen" is just okay!"
And start a fucking coup
d'etat over it, right?
It's like I'm just some fucking-
Yeah, I just don't get it.
It's fine to be influenced
by certain things,
but at the same time, it's
like, it's just a show, bro.
- I think it's a good
problem to have in our job.
- Of course
- People would spend many years
trying to get to the point where,
well, we're very fortunate
where people watch Trash Taste
and people care.
I feel very lucky that
people wanna get angry
about small things I joke about.
- Yeah, that's fine.
Is it a contention for
cancellation, though?
Not sure about that.
- I dunno, it goes back
to my online hate days.
I've gone to the point now where
it doesn't really bother me
that much at all, really.
It's interesting.
I think this is just 'cause
I've been online for so long now
where now I'm just kind
of in equilibrium with it.
I'm like, I don't know.
- Yeah, I wouldn't even say it's because
I'm okay with it now or I'm numb to it.
I think Jessica Nigri said it best.
She said, when someone
asked her about like,
"How do you deal with internet hate?
How do you get over it?"
And she said like, "You never get over it.
It still hurts, but you
just learn to live with it."
- To me, 'cause we have
talked about this a few times,
but to me, without getting
to the online hate thing,
the one thing that annoys me
than just people actually
just hating on me
and hating on my content, for example,
is just when people are trying
to put words in my mouth.
To be like, "Garnt said this,
or Garnt said this and that means X
or that means X, Y, Z."
And to me, there's nothing that
wants to make me reply more
than people who are
spreading this idea that-
- That's the greatest bait of all though.
- It is, right? It is.
- Because at that point,
I've seen some instances
where I say one thing, right?
And then it just spirals
out into this insane story
about how I fucking killed
a child or some shit, right?
(all laughing)
It's that level of how did you take
this one little piece of information
and spin it in a way
that just couldn't be
further from the truth?
You are basically writing a
fan fiction at that point.
And it's like, what?
And then there are people
who look at that and be like,
"Oh, yeah. That sounds
like something he'd say."
I'm like, what?
- I've been thinking about that a lot.
- 'Cause I swear to God, I don't
know if the Anime community
was always like this.
Because, to me, there are some topics
that I always used to love
arguing about, you know?
Because I felt like, to me,
there's some things where
you really have to be careful
about what you say in terms of religion,
politics and stuff like that.
- Hence the reason why we never
talk about it on the show.
- We've spoken about a
little bit on Trash Taste.
- But we try and avoid
it as much as we can.
- But you know, sometimes
you just want to have
a fun argument with someone
where you can just shit on their opinion
and you don't have to worry about it
'cause you know that,
at the end of the day,
the topic doesn't really matter that much.
And to me, as an Anime fan,
Anime was always one
of those topics for me
until quite recently.
And I don't know if
that's just my perception.
'Cause another topic I would say
you can easily argue with
anyone about is food.
Everyone loves arguing about food,
we do it all of the fucking
time, 'cause it's fun.
And it's fun because people understand
that people have different
tastes and opinion, right?
And to me, Anime was
always at that same level,
as I can easily argue
about anyone with Anime
and not have to worry about
hurting their feelings too much
because I just assume
everyone in our community
has an understanding that,
Dude, you can have your own taste.
You can have your own opinion.
- It's a mutual agreement
that at the end of the day,
even if this one random internet person
doesn't think that your
favorite shows as good as it is,
it's like, "Well, that's
not gonna deter me
from the fact that I still
like this show, right?"
- It's really just changed
just 'cause of the scale
of Trash Taste, right?
There was nothing like
this back in the day.
Back on "PodTaku", what was
the average viewer count?
- I think our most viewed
podcast ever was 100K.
- Which back then was crazy
for a podcast, that's insane.
- Yeah, it was crazy.
- Obviously the scale is
completely different now.
Anime has also been somewhat
more democratized in a way.
- Democratized.
- It's more readily available.
- Yeah, it's more
available to more eyes now.
- It's a lot easier to get ahold of.
And discourse about it is way more open
and people are way more
open to talk about it.
So I think that's some of the reasons why.
- So the problem is
it's getting to popular.
(Garnt laughing)
- Well, essentially!
- You could almost say
it's becoming mainstream.
- Kinda.
I always had this image that
the Anime community felt
like it was about 10,
five, 10 years behind hat we saw
with the gaming community, right?
'Cause it felt like
maybe the gaming industry
also had this shift where games used to be
just these fun things you
numb your brain out to,
it didn't really matter that much.
You could just have your have fun with it.
And then now games are a big business.
- It's the same essentially.
I know that some people gave
"Zelda: Breath of the Wild"
a seven out of 10 when it came out
and they got controversy for that,
'cause they didn't give it
a nine or 10 or something.
- So basically they
got canceled for saying
"Breath of the Wild" was just okay?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- No, they said it was just good.
- Oh, it's just good!
- Okay would be five!
We've had the same thing.
It's the same thing again, right?
- Isn't it incredible how one word
can completely change everything?
There's such a huge
difference in like insinuation
between calling something good
and calling something just good.
- It could be the attitude
towards it as well.
I think sometimes...
I can understand sometimes
the way you talk about Anime
could definitely...
You're like, "Yeah, it's mid."
And I can understand
why you piss people off
because you sound like you won't even
entertain the conversation.
You're like, I fucking hate the fact
that you even brought this up to me.
It was mid. Stop talking to me about it.
So I can understand why
sometimes people can get
annoyed by that.
'Cause they're like, "I wish
Joey just even listened to me."
It's like me trying to get
approval for my parents.
(Garnt laughing)
it's like, "I wish my parents
just gave it a chance."
- It's like, "No.
It's shit. No."
- You're like, "It's mid."
I think maybe that's what annoys people.
- Yeah, and look, I can
completely get that as well.
And that is my bad, to be fair.
But at the same time,
sometimes I don't even bother
engaging in these conversations
because I already know how it's gonna end.
- I get you, Joey.
Because it's just happened
so many times that-
- I've done this for almost nine years.
I know how a conversation
like this is gonna end.
- I've known you for ages,
so I know how you are
with these conversations.
- Yeah, I could say I
could give out all these
well thought out constructed arguments
about why I think the show is okay,
and people would be like.
"But, but, but, but, but, but, but!
But I don't agree!"
And I'm like, "Oh my God,
what more can I say?"
- So what you're saying is
if Trash Taste started six years ago,
you might have got more
enthusiastic debate out of Joey.
- Dude, this would actually
be an Anime podcast.
(Garnt laughing)
If it started six years ago.
- No, I don't want an Anime podcast!
- But no, it's not.
It's not now.
- Its not now.
- Great.
(all laughing)
- Thank God!
- Going back to the hate thing,
'cause you always get asked
by new creators or something
or anyone, how do you
deal with online hate?
What's the advice that you give someone?
'Cause I've been mulling
this over a lot recently,
'cause I think my opinion on
it has changed quite a lot.
- Since the last time
we talked about this?
- I think so.
I had this perspective shift
recently and I don't know why,
but I was like,
the whole thing of
living with it and stuff
is totally valid advice and
I think that's also good,
but I dunno what happened,
but now I look at it and
I don't really care at all
when I see it, because to me in my head,
they're never angry at me
as an individual person
when I read that.
They're angry at like
what they think is me.
- Right.
- Right?
They're not angry at..
If they sat with me and spoke with me,
they probably wouldn't
feel that way, right?
But they're angry at the idea of me,
and more often than not, it's like,
they were never gonna
give me a chance anyway,
'cause I must be a
personality they don't like.
- Yeah, see, but I feel that
way of thinking about things
has only been constructed
because you've been doing
this for so long, right?
- Yeah, definitely.
- And I don't think,
there are very, very few people
who can come right into
this industry from the jump
and have this enough self
confidence in themselves
and their content and their
self image on the internet
to be like, "Well, that's not about me.
That's just about their image of me."
And I feel like, especially
when I started off,
I didn't have that kind of
fucking confidence, right?
And I'm sure a lot of people didn't.
So anything, the moment
your name gets mentioned
in something, and even if it's not exactly
the most detrimental thing,
jab at your personality or whatever,
I think people just not used to this
and having this random amount
of people coming up to you
and being like, "By the
way, you're kind of shit"
is a thing that we're not
really used to, right?
- Yeah, the human wasn't
evolved to deal with it.
- How many people just
walk down the street
and have a random person be
like, "Excuse me, you're shit."
It doesn't happen, right?
But on the internet, that's normal.
- Yeah, that's like New York.
(all chuckling)
- Who was it that said
people on the internet
have gotten way too used to saying things
and not getting punched
in the face for it.
- Yeah! No, absolutely.
There's no repercussion for it, right?
They just think, "Oh, it's just free range
to say whatever the fuck I want."
- Oh, sorry. Go ahead.
- Oh, no, no.
And I was about to say,
and yes, in a sense, it
is kind of free range
to say whatever you want,
but with repercussions.
You can say whatever you want,
as long as you are willing
to pay for the repercussions
if they come back to you, right?
And they very may well might,
- Yeah, 'cause I actually had
to train my mum up for this,
recently, right?
'Course she's not getting hate,
but sometimes she goes
through the Trash Taste videos
and some of the streams and the comments
and she finds these comments.
And like, "Garnt, I
want to reply right now.
I wanna tell them that they're wrong!"
And I'm like, "Mum.
Do not do that, Mum.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
That's even worse, Mum!"
- Your mum wants to call out the haters?
- My Mom does that. Cause my Mom,
my Mom reads like so
many comments and like,
she doesn't understand how to
like how to deal with online
hate, especially to like her own son.
So she's just, she just like,
well sometimes she'll just like, send me,
like a bunch of comments being like,
look at all these people saying
wrong information about you.
I wanna reply, I wanna reply-
- Is that like a
Southeast Asian Mom thing.
'Cause Archie's Mom does
exactly the same thing.
- Where she had to be like,
Mom, stop sending me this shit.
Stop replying to this shit.
Just leave it.
I'm fine.
- I literally love to explain to her.
It's like, if a school
bully said something to me
and you come up to the school
bully in front of everyone in
the school, and be like, don't
talk about my son like that,
I'm like, Mom, this looks even worse.
And even if I replied
to her personally, okay.
- Oh no, no.
How did she take it?
- I told her not to do it.
I'm just like, just don't read it, Mom.
I understand what you're going through.
Everyone who's a content creator
goes through this at the beginning,
but you just gotta understand
that people are just gonna
say stuff.
- And actually couldn't be
more the opposite of that.
Like my parents would be like, oh,
my dad would be like, oh yeah.
Some people are saying about
your last video. And I'm like,
really? He's like, yeah,
but they're all dicks.
Don't worry about it.
- You'll be all right mate.
Perhaps I'm just waiting for
the day where I wake up on
Twitter one day and then I
wake up to like a screenshot.
That's been spread viral about
my Mom replying to like one
of my haters coming, be like,
"Yo, have you seen what Garnt's
Mom said to this person?"
I'm like for fuck's sake.
- I just wanna see a tweet
from your Mom being like,
what the fuck did you say you little shit?
(mumbles indistinctly)
- Now you know, I have three
hundred confirmed kills.
- Oh my God. I love that.
- I think we should read
some comments from your Mom.
I think that's-
- That yeah, definitely.
- I think that'd be good.
We should have a segment.
We read out your mom's reply comments.
- Have your parents ever like
looked through your comments
or looked through your videos?
See what people are saying about you?
- I think so.
I think my Mom one time was
like really sad about it.
She's like,
why are they saying mean things
there's on this one thing
about you. Right?
I was like, don't worry about it.
It's not a big deal.
- She's like,
- It's so cute though.
- Yeah. She was way more
upset about it than I was.
Yeah. I was like, don't give a shit.
But obviously,
'cause it's not normal to see
people bad mouth your son.
- Son. Right?
- Of course.
- Of course
It's not a normal thing.
You get to experience.
- Of course - It's quite
a visceral emotion.
- I mean I'd be lying if I said if,
my kid was in that situation,
I wouldn't do the same thing, all right.
- Oh, yeah. I probably
want to punch someone.
- Yeah
- I'd be like, don't
worry they're just dicks
- Yeah.
- Like honestly I kind of get it.
I'm the same, I guess,
because I feel like more anger
when I see you people shit
talking Sydney (mumbles)
- Oh, yeah. Same.
Like if I-
- I'm just like if I see
one persons shit talking
one of my bros, I'm
just like fuck that guy.
- Yeah.
- I wanna fucking call them out now.
- And I guess like if in that vein,
I think the one thing I hate
more than people taking my shit
outta context, right
and trying to cancel me for
something completely unrelated
is when they just like
drag my friend into it.
And especially people who
like don't matter at all.
I'm like, okay, you can
say shit about me, right?
Like I'll take care of that.
That'll be my problem.
But don't drag people who have
nothing to do with this shit
don't drag in my girlfriend or
my friends or like my fucking
Mom or anything like this.
It's got nothing to do with them.
If you hate my opinion, just shit talk me.
I'll deal with it.
I'll cry into my own pillow
but I don't want people
shit talking other people.
That's like the one thing
I hate, don't do that.
You're a dick if you do that.
- You're a dick if you do that.
- This episode is sponsored by Honey.
The easy way to save when
shopping on your iPhone
or computer.
- Guys how do you feel
about shopping online?
- I enjoy it, it's very handy.
- I'm not a shopping person.
- Well you do, you do
it quite often, right?
- Of course.
- I mean, of course we
don't leave the house.
Do you want to save more money?
- Hell yeah, of course.
- Thanks to Honey.
Manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past.
So you can save money, that easily.
Honey's a free shopping tool
that scours the internet for
promo codes and applies the best ones
that it finds to your cart.
- Imagine, you're shopping on
one of your favorite sites.
When you get to the checkout,
the Honey button appears
and all you have to do
is click apply coupons.
Wait a few seconds for Honey
to search for the coupons to
confine for the site.
And if honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch the prices drop.
- Boys is this the Valentine's weekend
as we're recording this?
what did you save on?
- Well, I chipped out and I
bought some flowers for Sydney.
Don't tell her, but I saved
so much money thanks to Honey
- How was did you save Garnt?
- I saved a whole 15 bucks
- On flowers?
- On flowers.
- They're basically
giving it to you for free.
- I know.
Don't tell Sydney
- But these, you know, gentlemen
that Honey doesn't just
work on desktop.
It works on your iPhone too.
Just activate it on Safari on your phone
and you can save on the go.
- On the go.
- on the go. If you
don't already have Honey,
you could be straight up missing out
and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and supporting the boys as well.
- I'd never recommend
something I don't use.
So get Honey free today
@joinhoney.com/trashtaste
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste
- Back to the episode.
- This is all like, what
is it like quarterly,
YouTube Twitch ran podcast I'd say.
- Yeah.
- I mean, yeah. I know a lot
of people might not empathize
with us 'cause we do talk about it a lot.
And I dunno if for an
audience is tiring ever,
but I kind of feel like we-
- It's therapy session.
- We need this every once in a while.
Otherwise we do gonna have
like this half emotion in us.
And we just every so often
I just need to let out.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Of course I just need to let out,
I feel like for content
creators, it's healthy
And it's like to me being able to talk
to other content creators about it.
It's a healthy way to get all
of this like toxicity out of
yourself and just get on with your life.
- Yeah.
I think before Trash Taste
definitely would need
to talk to another content
creator every now and then
just rant. Just needed it.
'Cause it's better to rant
to another content creator
than do it on a video or on a stream.
- Oh yeah definitely.
- I got a question.
Have you guys ever like tried
to explain when you're like
going through some controversy
or something's going on,
you have to try and explain it
to someone who just does not
understand YouTube and
it's just more involved in-
- Oh, yeah.
- It doesn't work.
I'm just like, don't worry about it.
It's a little annoying right now.
It'll pass.
- Yeah.
No, like, no hate against anyone.
We explain this to,
because to their credit,
they tried their hardest to
understand what's going on,
but like-
- I don't get it.
- Yeah.
I remember I had to like pretty
early on in my career when
I was getting that first
initial wave of like,
you're notable enough in the
community now where people
outside of your community
you'll find people some
people shit talking you-
- Part of it was me.
- Something like that, yeah
- What did you say Joey.
- I mean it is
- Just kidding. But like when
you first start to get that
first wave and you're like,
Oh fuck, I don't know who to
talk to about...
I dunno, I'm getting canceled.
Blah, blah, blah.
Even though it was like
barely nothing, right?
I remember I was talking to
one of my schoolmates about it
being like, yeah.
So like these bunch of people like coming
into my comment section saying that I suck
and blah, blah, blah.
And I remember one of them
was just straight up, like,
"Just tell 'em to fuck off!"
I was like, yeah, thought about that.
Not an option unfortunately,
when it's one of me and many others,
who I'm up against not
really that easy, Is it?
- Yeah. 'Cause-
- If only it was that easy-
- If only 'cause like,
I remember like every time
I've tried to explain something
that's been going on in
this YouTube's field,
some controversy, you're
just like, oh, okay.
So this person said this and
it's pissing a bunch of people
off like, holy shit,
Twitter's getting angry.
And then you talk to the
person they're like, oh,
why people getting angry?
- And you just, like-
- I said, this Anime was bad.
- Well so this person
said this Anime was bad
and these group of people
got pissed off about it.
And then they goes, so why
are they pissed off about it?
And then you keep going layers
and layers deep until you get
to a point where they just
forget what the original
like what people are
getting angry for about-
- Or it's to the point where
you're like the more arguments
come through and the
more layers down it goes,
you just start to realize,
wait, it's not a problem.
- Yeah (chuckles)
- There's no problem to begin
with. I'm just making it.
- Yeah. I mean, like I remember
back in the day where drama
could be addressed with
just one short Tweet longer.
- Yeah.
And now it's got to a point
where you need like a four hour
breakdown to understand
like the full depth
of some of this drama.
And I dunno when that shift happened,
when it was just like, okay,
now you need a fucking thesis.
Like it's a full on dissertation
to break down the...
like a play by play of like
the entire month leading up
to this one tweet.
- Except instead of one
professor like marking it down.
It's the entirety of
the internet being like,
But did you use correct citations for it?
No marks.
- Do we have the receipts?
- Do you have the receipts?
- Yes.
- Yeah. It's crazy how, especially
that side of the internet
has evolved, especially like,
I think, drama culture is kind
of a thing now where-
- Oh, it's definitely.
Well, I see some content
creators who start off
doing their own thing...
and a lot of people I've seen,
have just slowly shifted into
just like drama channels,
maybe intentionally
maybe not intentionally,
but it seems like every other
lot blow seems to be talking
about some kind of drama or
some kind of controversy that's
going on.
- Yeah.
- It's very good for business though.
- Oh, definitely.
- It's one of those things
where if you are in drama
that isn't really drama,
Like you said you have a bad take on Anime
or something, all right?
Those kind of drama are just
generally just good for you.
- Yeah.
- Because there's no real
downside 'cause nobody
who actually watches you gives a fuck
that you said a show is bad.
Like when I said 86, I
didn't like 86 right?
There's a lot of people mad about that.
But I doubt there was
many people who are like,
I can't watch Trash Taste
or Connor ever again.
'cause you said my favorite show is bad.
But maybe other people
who are watching you
or some people outside of it,
see this drama and think this
is really fucking stupid.
I'm not gonna check them out or
I'm more familiar with their
name through this drama.
'Cause drama is a really good way of...
I feel like a click on a
drama video is like much more
engaging than a normal clip.
- Oh definitely.
- So when you get like a
million views on a drama
- Yeah.
- The million views on that
drama video and maybe that's
such a generic gaming
video, they're not equal
the drama engagement and how
much people are invested is so
much more.
- Yeah.
- And especially if it's something
that paints you in a good
light or paints you in a way
that makes it look like you
didn't really do anything.
- Yeah.
- Then it's just great
for you because then now
you're just gonna get people
who are more invested in you.
People who think that
you've been done wrong.
- Yeah.
- And then they're gonna support you more.
- So when these people do this
shit they try and drag you in
the drama, this is why a
lot of big Twitch streamers
get into this kind of drama very often.
'Cause it's really good for
solidifying your base viewership
They wanna support you.
They they will help you.
And then people who see it and think, oh,
they weren't really in the wrong.
They might come and check
you out and feel a bit more
strongly about you.
'Cause they wanna support you.
'Cause they feel like
this is some bullshit
that was done to you.
- I feel like a drama video is like,
especially in multiple successions, right?
Of the same drama, like every day
it's almost like the world's
most engaging Let's play.
- Yeah.
In a sense where you are more likely,
if you are really into like a drama video,
you are more likely to come
back to that part than a regular
gaming video.
- I think it's just the
modern day reality TV show.
- Oh definitely.
- 'Cause like here's the thing.
Do you think people
actually care about drama?
Do you think people like-
- Only when it's like clearly
like there is a wrong person
who did a shit thing, right.
Like 90% of YouTube drama's not.
- I think there will be a
core audience that does feel
betrayed but I think the
majority people are there
just for the popcorn.
- Yeah
- I mean, of course.
- 'Cause, I remember like
the most recent drama
I can remember happening off
the top of my head right now
is the one that involved
"Pokemon" and "Ninja" right?
- Oh yeah
- And obviously that
got like a lot of views
when it came out and a lot
of people were discussing it.
But I remember like my first
initial reaction to hearing
about this drama that
was going on was okay,
what the fuck happened?
- It really hard to figure
out what was going on.
- It was so hard.
- As a content creator, I
was like trying to fucking
piece it together who was mad at who,
who did wrong to who, how did
it lead to this situation?
And they were like-
- Like it took Philly D
five minutes to explain it.
And that's a lot for Philly D.
- And I'm just thinking-
- One minute Russia's
invading one minute for that-
- Then five minutes of
"Pokemon" and "Ninja"
Legit, it was like that.
I was like, oh my God.
It was like the majority
of the video. It was crazy.
- I had like an easier time
understanding some of the
world situation going on right
now and the world politics
than like how this drama started
and the evolution of this
drama.
It was like, so surreal
like trying to figure out
what was going on ,right?
Because if me as a content
creator who knows the content
creators within this drama was
like having trouble figuring
out because I wasn't there
right at the beginning.
- Yeah.
- I can't imagine how a
general audience feels,
where they're it seems like
people are just seeing people
talk about this on their
timeline and they don't even know
you get to a point where you
kind of are waiting for someone
to tell you who you should be angry at,
- Right?
- Or who's in the wrong-
- And that's the problem.
I feel 90% of drama is not
so much about trying to
uncover the details,
gathering the receipts
and doing like a fucking
criminal investigation to who
started it and who's the
culprit, who's the victim.
It's literally just you
see a piece of drama,
like the "Pokemon" and "Ninja" one right?
- Yeah.
- And 90% of the audience just goes, okay,
so who am I rooting for?
- Yeah.
- Gimme two people to root for.
Gimme two people to fight for.
All right, it's "Ninja" and "Pokemon"
Well, I like that person
better just from the one thing
I've heard about them so
I'll just root for them.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it's not always
the case, but yeah.
- A lot of it is like that though.
You have to admit a lot of it's like that.
Especially if you're not in
that community or don't give a
shit about that community.
- Yeah.
- You know like if a bunch
of fucking fashion YouTubers
get into some drama, right?
- Like that's what they want though.
- Yeah. But that's what they want.
I'm not going to care about the details.
All I'm going to care about is okay,
So who are the two people in question?
And what is the general
consensus on these two people who
are fighting?
Like that's all it is to
me. Like other than that,
I don't give a shit personally.
- Yeah.
Even though it's good for business,
I don't think a lot of
these Twitch streamers
try to get into this stuff.
Some of them maybe do...
- Yeah.
- I know that. I don't
try to but I'm just brash
with my words and also not
very good at explaining
my arguments on the spot as
we all know from Trash Taste
- Yeah.
- So I end up getting into these things.
- A lot of people aren't
good at explaining
their arguments on the
spot, which I think is where
the problem stems from.
'cause, I would like to
think that we're all very
well spoken and are on the board-
- I can be well spoken but like-
- When I want to be.
- You can be, you can be.
But it's hard.
It's hard where you have so
many hours of content around
yourself, just talking and
just not just Trash Taste,
but Twitch streamers as well,
especially with Twitch streamers
where they are basically on
camera, live in an audience
like eight hours a day plus,
there's going to be a time
where you are not as careful
with your words where you slip up a bit,
and that's just going to happen.
it will happen to anyone
in the same situation.
- [Joey] Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- That's deep.
- That deep (laughs),
- That's deep Man
- That hit me right there.
- That deep.
- Damn that's deep. God.
That's deep.
You know something that Twitch
streaming is made me feel
a lot more.
I really feel a lot more strong
about the viewers who like
turn up like every day to the shit.
I don't know why.
'Cause you when you're YouTubing,
I see that fucking...
who's that ninja guy who
comments on every video?
- The guy without (mumbles)-
- It's like there's like
500 of these channels right?
You're like the same
people can't whatever.
But like on the Twitch I know
a bunch of the names of people
who like turn up every single time.
There's this person called
BlueSkyDays who every
single stream gives me five subs.
And I feel like they've
made it into a ritual.
I swear there you go.
This is your shout out,
Thank you, I really appreciate it.
Again, going back to the hate
stuff it's like, all right.
When I think about getting sad
about some people not liking
what you do or whatever, I'm like, okay.
But like how much more would
it hurt me If I had to explain,
to say that person who
maybe turns up all the time,
Hey, by the way, I'm
quitting. I don't like this.
'Cause some people said
mean things about me.
I feel like seeing that person be like,
oh, you're gonna quit, but
I like watching your stuff.
That would hurt me way more
than anything anyone could say
like, oh yeah,
- Of course,
- Connor's fell off ratio,
whatever that nothing,
- Yeah.
- Of course.
- I mean to me, I feel the same
with like some of my patrons
because I have patrons
who have been fans of me,
who have been watching me
since like 10 years ago
or something and they've
been there since the start
of when I opened my patron
and they're still with me
to this day.
And I'm just like that's fucking insane
Shout out to all you guys in
the patron discord server,
I like having my patron and
discord server because it's just
like a very close knit
community and it's nice having
just familiar faces that have
just, stuck with you for that
long
It makes you feel, what's
the word not validated,
but just happy that you
kind of do what you do
- Yeah. Very much.
- I definitely feel that way
as well about YouTuber friends
who were there since the
very beginning, right?
I have a couple who were
still around back when I had
fucking less than a thousand subs, right?
I was doing like gaming
videos and shit like that...
Again, same thing.
If I were to just one day, be like, yeah,
I kind of just fucking hate this.
People are shitting on
me, blah, blah, blah.
It's like betraying a
family member at this point.
They've been there, they've
seen thick and thin of me
and being like, nah, dude, you got this.
And they've believed
in me the entire time.
And then for me to just be like,
I can't take a bunch of people
giving me shit for saying
that "Jujutsu Kaisen"
was okay then I'm sorry-
- I was considering it in the podcast.
I was like fuck Joey-
- I have to go I'm sorry
- He's ignorant as fuck
- Didn't like "Jujutsu Kaisen".
I'm done. It's over with.
- I didn't say I didn't like it.
Yeah, It's okay.
- You didn't come.
- It's it's just okay.
- That is offensive to
everything I hold dear.
- The more you say it, the
more offensive it sounds.
- Stop, stop.
- I dunno how this is happening.
- Am I supposed to
rephrase? It was average.
- It wasn't average.
I'm not even gonna entertain
you on this, it was better than
average, come on.
- Why do you think I don't
wanna start these conversations?
- These are the kind of people
that'll say it's average and
then give "Love Life" a seven
out 10 you know what I mean?
I can't stand this.
- I don't even want get into "Love Life"
dude, are you kidding me? Fuck that!
- That is the conversation.
- All the "Love Life" fans-
I'm not gonna engage in for good reason.
- I know a lot of "Love Life"
fans I'm hating on you guys.
I'm sorry-
- They won't take it that way.
They'll be like, I can't
believe you took this as a joke.
- Here goes my L this week.
- There's your cancellation for the week
- I was gonna say we're very
fortunate that in YouTube,
it's quite difficult to have
good friendship with other
YouTubers for a long period
of time, just 'cause of
the nature of the job.
- Oh, definitely.
- It just, things change,
people get busy, people move,
people get on with their
life, do different content,
fall off ratio, all that kind of stuff
like the work. So, we're very very lucky
there were some good
friends and we've been
friends with a very long time.
We all happen to kind of be
around the same kind of sphere
and do the same thing, same time.
And it all kind of worked out very lucky.
- And I think that's like
another thing as well.
If we're going back to
helpful advice for people
starting off, right?
Like another one that I get often, as well
Oh what do I do about collabing and stuff?
because I feel that's like
the easiest way to grow out
your channel from an
early stage. And I'm like,
yes, in a sense, if you do it right.
But you shouldn't be like
a channel with 200 subs
and fucking DM-ing Felix,
to collab with you, right?
You gotta know your boundaries
and stuff like that.
And also like another piece of
advice that I saw on Twitter
the other day which I
thought was very true.
I think a lot of YouTubers
especially those starting off
have this weird misunderstanding
that they think everyone
who collabs with them is
also a friend of theirs.
And that is just, unfortunately not true.
There are a lot of people who
just see it as business who
just want to do this one time
thing or just to do this thing
to benefit themselves. But also,
the person they're collaborating with.
And it's almost unhealthy to
see a person who you collab
with as just your mate, right?
Like there's a very big
difference between a collaborator
and an actual friend.
- Yeah.
And I think once you've really
fully started to understand
at an early stage and really
gone and thought to yourself,
okay, who is actually my friend?
Like someone who will hang out
with me when the cameras are
not rolling.
And who is someone that is
just there for the clout?
- Do you have a hard
time drawing that line?
- No
- It's like, I-
- I've done this for long
enough now where I know-
- It's like being an adult.
God forbid, I've become an adult,
you kind of learn to
just vibe with people.
Sometimes you don't vibe with people.
Sometimes you really love what they make
and you really like how they go about it.
And sometimes you hang out with them
and it just didn't click,
it's kind of weird.
The conversation wast little, Oh, okay.
And other times it's like, holy shit,
I gotten so well with this person,
but then maybe you feel
that way and they don't,
which is this is experience
thing we have to learn.
All right. Okay.
Even if I really like that
person, I liked hanging out
with them, I want to talk to them again.
You gotta be like normal about it.
Don't be like, let's hang
out next day. Let's do it.
- Yeah
- I space it out of it.
- Yeah. I don't know
how we got to like that.
I don't know how we became super close,
'cause I remember there was
definitely a time when I was
yeah, these guys are cool,
but I don't wanna like burden them.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I don't wanna text them too much.
'Cause I remember when I met
Garnt we didn't really talk
in between hanging out.
It was kind of like we'd hang out.
And then it was like a
thing, I don't really know.
- I mean, you sent me a fucking email.
- An email, I dunno how that work.
I would've put that right in the trash.
- I'm the type of guy who
really connects with someone
hanging out.
- Yeah, same.
- Hanging out personally or physically-
- Garnt needs to touch your
face, make your sweat suck your-
(all laughing)
- I don't know the fuck
you're talking about that.
- I was sexually harassing you.
- You are not a friend of
mine until I suck your dick.
- Garnt is Harvey white.
- I was going to mention I'm
the type of guy who might not
talk so much like online or on the phone-
- No, I was joking.
Garnt does not sexually harass people.
- It was just visual,
like whiplash for me.
'Cause I was trying to
make this poignant point
and it just kind of goes,
"Garnt sucks dick, he's like sweat"
I'm just what did I say?
What did I say?
- I can confirm that was
a weird time at the onset.
Pretty sure I was told that what he did
- Yeah. Because I remember
we didn't message too much,
but I had a fun time hanging
out whenever we did hang out
in person and we just ended up
hanging more times in person.
I guess it just happened naturally, right?
Going from what you said
about being friends versus
collaborators, even me as
someone who doesn't collab
too much, I barely collab at
all, as a content creator...
There are some content creators
who you enjoy that content
and you really respect
the work that they do.
But there are some people
that you just think,
I probably wouldn't get along with you.
I love the work you do,
but I probably would
not get along with you.
And on the opposite end,
there are also other people
who you don't like their content,
but maybe I can get along with this guy.
- Definitely.
- Seems like it seems like
a chill dude or something.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And it's that whole thing of
like separating the artist
from the art.
Which is way easier said
than done in a lot of cases.
- Yeah. It's just tough.
- It just feels like it's been
so long since I've been able
to meet a lot of new content
creators who I've watched
because of the past two years.
Because we've only been able
to meet people in Japan.
And I feel normally like
you get a point every year
where you get to this opportunity
to fly out out to America
or fly out to somewhere,
fly out to conventions
and actually meet fellow content creators.
And I've forgotten what
that feels like now.
I've forgotten what it feels
like to have the first awkward
meeting of oh, hey I watch your stuff.
I like what you do
- I mean like, thanks. Wanna take a photo?
- I'm just getting to
speak English to people.
I just wanna speak English to someone.
- Do you remember the first
time you met someone online?
Who you knew online?
But you'd never like met in real life.
Do you remember what that feeling's like?
'Cause one of the biggest
things I first noticed it's
always height. Always Heights.
- Oh yeah.
- They are never the height
you expect them to be.
- Oh yeah. Absolutely.
- That's true on my end as
well, because every time someone
meets me that's the first
comment. Every time.
- It's either height or
depending on if you're a content
creator who shows their face or not.
It's also like how they look as well.
I definitely got that when I
first met John Super Eyepatch
Wolf because almost all his videos
he never shows his face.
So for the longest time people
didn't know what he looked
like and then obviously
when he first blew up,
everyone was like, all the
AnimeTubers were like this guy's,
content's fucking amazing. It's great.
I would love to meet him.
And then when we heard
that he was coming to AX,
it was like a fucking AX guest.
He was like, yo hype, Super
Eyepatch Wolf is coming to AX
dude, let's fucking go.
And then you go to the gathering.
And there's a bunch of faces
there that you think might be
Super Eyepatch Wolf, all right.
But you don't know who, right?
Because you've never seen his face.
- Yeah.
- And then when you meet him, finally
I remember the first I said to John,
I was like, "I'm sorry if this is weird,
but you are like really hot."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I mean, he is.
- If I was a chick, I would
be head over heels for him.
- He's the Sigma male.
- He really is.
And luckily he took it in like a good way.
- That fucking jaw line man
dude, John, please that man.
- Dude, he could break
bricks with that jaw.
it's crazy how hot he is.
- Why aren't you not more on camera?
- I Know.
- You need to show your face more John.
You're a good looking dude.
- Although he did buy a Dell
computer that was gonna-
- Oh yeah.
- That was a great video.
- Yeah.
- Imagine buying a Dell computer.
It couldn't be me.
- When it comes to like looks as well,
but also like physique
and as you said height.
I get my height pointed
at all the goddamn time
and I never thought that
would be a weird thing.
- Yeah.
- Did you ever meet up
with people online often
before YouTube was ever that
a thing you ever used to do?
- No, not really.
- Yeah. 'Cause I feel like I
made online friends because of
YouTube
- [Joey] Yeah same.
- And not the other way around.
So especially during the
pandemic with more people,
making friends online,
I'm sure a lot more people are
going to be experiencing this
experience, but it was like
an alien experience to me
the first times I did.
And like, it's still weird.
I never get used to meeting
someone who I know online.
And especially if they're
like a content creator,
it feels so weird now 'cause
I'm a content creator and
I've been on the other side of it.
And sometimes I just don't know
how to approach someone who
whomst I know that's-
- It's so weird.
It's that feeling of meeting
that content creator that
you've only seen in video in person and,
and the first thing that
pops into your mind is.
I've only ever seen you behind a screen.
That mentality never dies.
It's so weird.
Even though I'm also in that
same position now to that
other person.
- It's so weird. One of
my first thoughts is,
"Oh, that's what the back
of their head looks like."
(all laughing)
I dunno why.
Because it's just not an
angle you've ever seen.
So it's just weird.
It's so surreal seeing
this angle, I'm just like,
" Is that that person?"
And it's just like, Oh
wait, no, it is that person.
Oh, okay.
- I kinda get what you mean
- I had this really painful
fucking cringe thing I did.
- All right.
- I was at an AX party, right?
- Yeah.
- I was chilling and you kind
of bump into people that you
somewhat recognize or maybe you know them,
you've spoke to them once,
you go over and say hi and stuff.
And I was at this party and
there was a group of people
like five content creators, influencers,
whatever you wanna call them.
- Yeah.
- That I didn't really know,
but there's one person who
I saw them and I was like,
Oh, I know that person. I
had just met them in the UK
so I went over to go say hi.
And I was like, "Oh hi, nice
to see you, how you doing?
we hung out in the UK"
Turns out it wasn't that person.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I had mistaken them. And I
thought it was them and I shit
You not...
I hadn't even drank that much.
It was like one, one or two drinks.
And even though I like
wasn't drunk at all,
I somehow sobered up, even
though I'm still sober.
I was like sorry about that.
I was like, yeah, I know you and stuff
and she's like it's not me.
And I'm like, Oh, you really
look like this person.
I really thought you this person.
I could have maybe died on
this sword and get out my
phone and be like, you
look really like this,
but no, it wasn't.
And yeah, it was a really
awkward thing where I was like,
oh, that's really embarrassing.
I'm really sorry about that,
- Yeah
- I hope you guys have
a good time. Ignore me.
And then I walked away really awkwardly
like, why am I so cringe?
- Have you met fans who have
kind of been like that as
well? Like-
- Yeah. I don't care.
I'm indifferent towards
it, but I know it's-
- I guess that's how they feel, right?
- Yeah.
It was like five content
creators. It's like, great.
Now they're all gonna think,
I'm this fucking weirdo.
That just approaches people and
goes, "Are you this person?"
And then-
- It's me, look.
- Gotta think I'm blind.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
And then when I went home,
whatever, I followed the-
- So was it another
content creator or was it?
- It was another content creator,
I was mistaking them with
another content creator
who happened to be in like the
same field and stuff as well.
And it was also really
awkward 'cause I'm sure...
they recently followed me on
Twitter and I wonder if they
remember me going up to them
like three years ago doing
this.
If I ever meet them,
I'm gonna ask them again
if they remember.
- My favorite interaction of
that that's kind of similar,
I was on the opposite end though.
Was in Singapore AFA when I
went with Garnt and there was
this one moment.
- I'll never fucking forget.
I'm sorry if you watch this show.
I was walking with Garnt and
Allen and Sydney through the
convention hall.
- Yeah.
'Cause I was on my way to
something and this dude spots me
from across the hallway.
And he's looking me dead
in the fucking eyes.
So I'm like, Oh, he clearly knows me.
So I just kind of waved
to him or whatever.
And he came up to me and he was like,
"Oh my God. Are you GiggUK?"
- I remember that I was
standing right behind you
- And imagine me this kid
so excited calling me GiggUK
and me having to go, No, but he is.
(Garnt mumbles indistinctly)
I totally forgot about that
- And Garnt's was just
like, Yep. I'm GiggUK.
'Cause I remember
thinking, I don't even know
how to feel about this.
There was a split second where I'm like,
this is a bit right?
This is a joke
- I'm just like, should
I be happy or offended?
I'm not sure. But I kind
of feel both right now.
Happy that obviously someone recognized me
but someone knows me.
But unhappy that I was literally
standing right here and
they go to Joey and goes, love
you, watch Joey, love you,
Watch Garnt
- I love your videos.
- Love your videos GiggUK.
- Love those Anime minutes.
- I was like yeah, you supposed
to talk to him about it.
- What did they do when you talk to him?
- At first I thought it was
like kind of a joke, right?
Being like, Oh, I'll just
say it's Joey ha ha ha funny.
I was waiting for him to be
like, Nah, I'm just kidding
And then actually turned towards Garnt.
- Yeah.
But the moment I kind of pointed to Garnt
and he looked at Garnt
his smile just dropped.
- He was like, Oh God, I
have made a horrible mistake.
I am so was sorry to the both of you.
I mean he still knew me though,
but I guess he just mixed
me and Garnt's usernames up.
- Yeah, he might have-
- Yeah, he might.
- He's a was nice kid so whatever.
But it was one of the funniest
interactions I've seen just
experienced as well.
- Have you ever had that
point where you told your fan
or something and they said,
Oh, I loved when you did X video
and you think to yourself
I didn't do that video.
- I didn't do that video.
- My favorite is when they're like-
- Sometimes I do
- If we're like having more
than a five minute conversation,
I'm just like I didn't make that video.
But sometimes they just
say this one comment
and they leave and I'm just
like, I won't ruin their day.
- I don't wanna think they
messed up, I don't care.
I don't want-
- My favorite for those that
I never have the heart to tell
them is when they're really
trying to sell you on the point
that they've been a fan
for a really long time.
And they're like, Oh Joey,
I love your stuff, man.
I've been watching you
since 2010 man, Like
it's great and I'm like, all right, bye.
And then at the back of my head, I'm like,
I started in 2013.
- [Connor] Yeah
- I don't really have the heart.
I was in high school in 2010.
So it would be scary if you
knew me back then Jesus Christ.
But I don't have the heart to tell.
I don't wanna be that guy, right?
To be like fake fan.
I don't wanna to do that to them.
- Dunno if I told this story.
I know I've told you guys this story.
I dunno if I said on the podcast
- All right.
- It was the meetup I did
with Book Walker at AX.
Where I just signed and took
pictures, the one Sydney,
he got like (mumbles) interrupting.
And the line was pretty long.
I was very happy with
myself. I was like, wow.
People actually want to
come and hang out with me?
I don't know how long the line took.
Maybe like 30 minutes. I don't know how...
- I think it was capped.
I think we all capped like an hour, right?
Something like that.
- So yeah.
Whatever study minutes and I'm doing that.
And one guy comes up to me
and I'm like, holy shit.
There's a guy here. He's like-
- This is back in your (mumbles)
- It was like it wasn't guys, right?
I appreciate it.
I was like, oh thanks man.
And so I'm like, Yo,
hi, how you doing, man?
He was like, oh, I'm good.
And then we take a photo and he is like,
Yeah man, could you sign
this "Goblin Slayer" book?
I really like the work you did on it.
And I was like coming in, he's like,
Are you not the author
for "Goblin Slayer"?
And I was like, (Garnt laughing) No
He was like, Oh, but I
thought this was like
a "Goblin Slayer" booth.
And I was like, No, I'm a YouTuber.
And in my head I was like,
Did this guy like look at the name on it?
I don't know who the author
of "Goblin Slayer" is,
but I'm guessing he
doesn't look like a Connor.
- His name's Kagyu Kumo. So
it's very different, yeah.
- Maybe this guy was like, I do not judge.
- I do not see race.
- I do not see country,
race, ethnic background.
He's like, I'm open to all walks of life.
- Maybe a white guy from
Wales could have written
a light novel and-
- This boy is very new.
Homegrown (mumbles) if
that's the case. Holy shit.
- I felt so bad for this kid because
I didn't care that he confused me,
but this guy was so embarrassed
I'd never seen a face drop that fast.
'Cause we'd taken the photo
shit and too on his phone
and I'm like, you can go
delete that. I won't be mad.
I signed this thing as well.
I signed his "Goblin Slayer" book
and then he tells me he loved
my work on "Goblin Slayer"
What was that a Goblin? or something
I didn't know what I
did on "Goblin Slayer"
I dunno if I should be
the defender or not.
- That's so funny.
'Cause I remember having
this one conversation once
with a fan, sometimes you
get into like pretty intense
conversation with fans
about some of your videos
or something when you have the time to.
So I remember this one
fan I think it was like AX
or one of the Anime conventions.
And we got into this conversation
about "Bleach" right?
And at this point I've said
my takes about "Bleach" a lot.
Whether on my videos, my first
video was a "Bleach" video
in other videos and podcasts (mumbles)
- But was just okay.
- Huh?
- Did you say it was just okay?
- I'm not gonna open that
box of worms right now,
but like I remember-
- Can of worms.
(Joey and Connor chuckling)
- I'm not gonna open that kind of worms.
So now, I remember were
having this fucking intense
conversation about "Bleach"
And he kept saying things like,
I remember when you said this
about the quick (mumbles)
and like this about Tite
Kubo, can you expand on that?
'Cause I don't agree with this.
And we were like having
this full debate about this.
And I remember thinking,
I don't remember saying
this about "Bleach"
but I might have said that about "Bleach".
So I'm just going to entertain
the idea of this debate
that he's having about me.
And so we go into this like
10 minute fucking debate about
"Bleach" right?
- Oh my God.
- And then at the end, I'm
just like, yeah, I finally
understand your Fall of "Bleach" video now
and I'm just like, that was John's video.
(all laughing)
- And at that point, I didn't
even have the heart to tell
him 'cause I'm just like, we've
been talking about a video
that I didn't make for 10 fucking minutes
and having a strong debate about it.
- How did he not realize that your voice
and John's voice is like
completely different?
- Like how did I not realize
that he was talking about a
video that I didn't make?
'Cause the thing is, I've talked
so much shit about "Bleach"
that sounds like something
I might have said.
I've talked a lot of
things about "Bleach".
I might have said that.
- It wasn't you arguing your opinions.
It was you agreeing with John.
- I was arguing John's opinion
without me being involved.
- Step aside John, I got this.
I got your back bro.
- I hope John appreciates that.
- You showed that guy out last year.
- I did. I did.
John, I'm fighting the good fight.
John, I'm fighting the fucking good fight.
- He's got his boxing gloves on for you.
Like he's fighting back.
Oh, my God.
- It's also that thing where
I have said so much stuff in
my years of being online that
I have forgotten a good chunk
of any jokes or anything I've made.
And I've had those awkward
moments where someone will make
a reference a video of mine
from like five, four years ago.
And I'll be like, What did you say?
- They said the thing and I'm like.
Why did did I say that?
- Now the worst is when
they ask you to say it.
Be like, I love this video that you made.
Can you say that one line? And I was like.
- I know I say it.
- No, but it's when
you don't remember what
they're talking about when it's
a video from a Let's
Play from six years ago.
It's like, say that one thing
you said in "Corpse Party"
in episode 42.
Remind me how it goes again.
- That's oddly specific.
Why would someone ask you that?
- I've had that before in the past, yeah.
I mean, I've made over a thousand videos.
I don't remember every single one I made.
- Yeah. It's been
extrapolated even fucking more
with Trash Taste now.
- Oh yeah.
- Where I will get comments
or I'll get like people-
- I'm so excited to have
people bring up my opinions
and I've totally forgotten.
- 'Cause, I've had conversations
with people I've met here
who obviously watch Trash
Taste and they were like,
and they say to me,
remember when you said this
and I'm just like, did I say that?
- No.
- I mean, that kind of
sounds like something I said,
I don't remember when I said
it, but like the "Bleach"
video, I'm just going to
assume that you are right.
And I did say that.
So let's just, entertain this idea
and have this conversation.
- Of course.
- Basically if you meet me
in a convention and you said,
Oh, you said this, what's
your opinion about it?
I'm probably just gonna
entertain that idea regardless of
whether I said it or not.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Let's talk about that.
- I love conventions so much, man.
This is my weekly reminder
that I miss conventions.
- God. I miss conventions so much.
I'm hoping out hope that we can-
- Well this year, be the year.
- This year be the year I'm hoping-
- I'm praying this of the year we finally
get to go to conventions.
- Let's find out.
- Yeah.
- One day.
- This episode is
sponsored by Magic spoon.
- Guys did you like cereal as a kid?
- Oh yeah, of course.
- But don't you wish the
cereal grew up with you?
Well, introducing Magic Spoon,
the perfect cereal for adults.
- If I'm reading this correctly,
it's zero grams of sugar,
13 to 14 grams of protein and
only four net grams of carbs
in each serving.
And that's only 140 calories per serving.
- Oh my God.
- Those are keto friendly,
gluten free, grain-free,
soy free and low carb.
- Let me try some now, let me eat.
- What have you got there?
- I got the cocoa flavor
right here.
- It's got nice crunch to it.
- Does it remind you of your childhood?
- It's so delicious. You can
barely keep it in your mouth.
- It actually really good.
Honestly, Magic Spoon sent
out a bunch of cereal boxes to
try out before and apart from these ones,
me and Sydney have already
finished all of them because
they're actually really, really good.
- I actually came to
the office this morning,
eating a bowl of these frosted ones.
- Like honestly, I'm going
to ask for more boxes
to be sent here, okay.
That's legit.
I might get actually get all
four boxes to be sent here.
- That's legit I actually love this stuff.
- So what are you waiting for?
Click the link down below to
grab a variety pack and try it
today and be sure to use
promo code Trash Taste,
to get $5 off any order or go
to magicspoon.com/trashtaste
and Magic Spoon is so
confident in their product.
It's backed with a 100%
happiness guarantee.
I wish I had that my own life.
So if you don't like it for any reason,
they'll refund your
money. No questions asked.
So click the link in the
description down below and use
coupon code Trash Taste
for $5 off or go to
magicspoon.com/trashtaste
to save $5 today.
- Get the Coco flavor.
This one absolutely slaps.
- The frosted flavor is also
it actually... they're all
really good.
- Really good
but this one's my favorite.
- Yeah. My favorite is
definitely the frosted one.
- Back to the episode.
- 'Cause we have a lot of
things planned for this year
that's outside of Japan,
not spawning anything more
than just that, but I'm hoping
that I get to interact with
people again
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's the biggest thing,
I missed the vibe of conventions,
I didn't realize how
much I missed it until
you couldn't go to it anymore.
I just missed that whole
convention vibe and the positive
air and the positive attitude
and having fun for a weekend.
- Yeah.
I just love the ambiance
of a convention hall
the low murmur everywhere and it's like-
- Like everyone's just excited-
- So everyone's just there
and excited and it's like,
you can feel the hype of
the room and it's like-
- I love the energy.
- It's smells.
- Yeah.
- I was gonna say I didn't
think I would miss the smell
of stale sweats that
you like smell when like
the convention-
- Speak for yourself.
I don't miss that, God-
- I don't miss it.
I just miss that that reminds
me that I am at a convention
and this is the smell of a convention.
- When you walk into like a
clean room and you're like,
damn it man, it ain't
that AX smell though.
It ain't that AX smell
- Air's too clean right now
- It's too clean right now.
- It definitely ain't the gaming area.
- Nah, there's not enough
precipitation in the air.
There's not enough game of
- I should miss it so much.
So especially when you get
those it'll be like a few months
or even like a year later
and someone they'll be like,
Oh I met Connor at X
and X. He was so nice.
And I'm like, that makes my day, man,
even though that might become
a meme now someone will be
I met Connor at his Twitch
chat, he was so nice.
He called me an idiot.
I don't know, I like being a dick online.
But then in person I'm like,
Oh man, I just wanna be nice to everyone.
- I want the opposite of that to be like,
Oh I met Joey at a
(mumbles). He was so nice.
I have subscribed
(all laughing)
- I think I've had that one time actually.
Someone's like, Oh, Connor
was so rude or something.
And I don't think I was
though I rarely would be rude.
I can scarcely be rude to myself.
Let alone like someone else.
- I'm only rude to my best mates.
That's basically it.
- Yeah. I mean sometimes you have to,
if you're being ushered to somewhere,
- Of course
- Sometimes people will start like,
Oh Joey, can I take a picture?
and I'll be like,
Oh, I can't right now
actually I have to have to go.
- There's only one of me and
many people who thankfully want
to hang with me-
- I hate being like, no,
I can't take a picture.
- I want to, but handlers
and staff and what not and-
- 1% Problems, eh?
- Yeah.
- You're living a good life.
- Duty calls you sometimes-
- It's so hard.
Just people wanting to
take a photo with me, God.
Oh, I'll wake up in the morning.
- I can't imagine.
What do I do with all this attention?
- I'm very, very grateful.
I'm very grateful.
- Connor you've changed.
You've changed Connor.
- I fell off the plus ratio.
- Before you moved to Japan,
did you guys get called
out by your username more
or by your real names?
Did anyone actually call
you by like Connor, Joey?
- I was always CDawg or
Sebastian occasionally
- They were like, "Yo Sebastian"
- Yeah. Remember that one
time we were in little Tokyo.
We were in L.A in little
Tokyo and we were chilling.
And then like, we were all
done with our delicious...
I think I didn't even have Japanese food.
I remember I had beeb and bub which is-
- Yeah.
It was like the like Korean
barbecue place, right? - Yeah.
- So we were leaving and it was good.
We were chatting and some girls
screamed like, "Sebastian"
and I was like, Oh God.
(Garnt laughing)
I was really just embarrassed
'cause you guys were
fucking laughing at me
'cause they called me Sebastian.
- Because it was that moment
of like we all turn around and
we were like, "Oh I
wonder which Seba.... Oh!"
- And Connor's just like...
- This is like been the
period where I was trying my
goddamn hardest to get away from it.
So it was like a reminder.
- I mean, yeah, definitely-
- I don't care if someone did it,
you can call me Sebastian.
I don't give a shit.
- I think it happened early
on where people at first were
calling me Anime man or whatever.
I think I from really
early on because too many
people were getting my usernames wrong.
And also the fact that I
didn't like my username-
- What were they calling
you then? If it was wrong
- Oh, there was Anime guy, Anime dude.
- It's not that hard.
- That's so true.
Like every time I hang
out, I was next to Joey.
I swear he would get like
Anime man maybe only like 70%
of the time.
- Yeah, If that.
- There's been so many
variations of your name.
- How that even hard to remember?
- But there were people who
would like get my actual name
wrong as well.
Like I've, I've been called John.
I've been called the one that
I couldn't fucking believe.
And I remember to this day was (mumbles)
Some dude legit came up
to me and said, "Hey Josh"
- With like a hundred percent confidence.
- With hundred percent
confidence. And I was-
- Man, respect to that guy
- I couldn't even be
like, it's Joey because
I was actually just dumbfounded.
I'm like you did not just
fucking call me that.
- Do you know like Josh?
Do you have a vendetta against Josh?
- Oh, nothing against Josh.
I've got mates called
Josh, but I'm not Josh.
- Why did the name Josh specifically
annoy you more than John?
- I think it's because
there's only ever been
that one guy who called me, Josh.
- Watch it now, next day, ex or whatever,
you're gonna be Josh, the Anime guy.
- I understand like Anime
guy or like Anime dude
or like a different derivative
of the word man, right?
Because it's a pretty generic name, right?
- The Anime man, it's pretty fucking easy.
- Well, I'd like to think so.
- But actually like-
- I think people have
gotten my internet handle
wrong almost as much times as
they've got as they got it right
- Yeah, probably.
- Yeah. Because I think the
biggest thing is obviously
people think my name's GiggUK.
- Yeah
- Yeah. They're like, oh, I love you.
I love your word GiggUK.
And I'm just like, how long
have you been watching my stuff?
- I think YouTube, should
implement those pronunciation
brackets that they have on
those like Merriam dictionary?
- They like the Google
translate, like say the word-
- Is my name that hard to
pronounce because I swear I've had
so many mispronunciations of
my name and it doesn't even
piss me off. I just find it funny, right?
- Yeah.
- I don't ever say anything.
I'm just like, whatever.
Well just-
- At least yours is
just a mispronunciation.
Mine is literally just
not the correct word,
- Josh
(Connor and Garnt giggling)
There's only so many
ways you could, like...
I didn't know you could
pronounce man as dude or guy.
- I think it's just because my entire life
is a mispronunciation of my name.
I'm just fucking GiggUK.
I think the weirdest
mispronunciation of my real name
actually when I was in university.
So I remember in university,
in Freshers week especially
you meet a lot of new people
very quickly and obviously,
as you all know Garnt is
not a common name at all.
- Right.
- And I've heard like every fucking
mispronunciations of my name by then.
And I remember my first day
of uni, I heard a new one.
So I go up to a person and
I say, "Hi, my name's Garnt"
thinking they'd say Grant, or Garnet or
one of like, something like that.
That happens a lot. Garnet happens a lot
- Really?
- Yeah.
And he goes "God, your name's God?"
I'm like what? How did you mishear that?
No, I almost said Grant, it's Garnt
- It's been confirmed, it's Garnet.
- It's Garnt.
'Cause how I explain it, it's Garnt.
Think of Grants, but swap
the R and the A over.
Yeah. So that's how I like
speed run explaining my name.
And he was just like, "Oh,
Garnt" and I'm thinking
in my head, what a fucking damn ass,
how would you hear God from Garnt, right?
That's just like the anomaly.
He's the glitch in the matrix.
And then literally like two people later.
I'm like introducing myself.
And so like later in the day
I say, "Hi, my name's Garnt."
And the second time,
"God, your name's God?"
I'm like, what the fuck is going on?
What is going on right now?
- I think it would be a
very bold move of a parent
to name their kid, God.
So very bold name.
You gotta have high hopes to that kid.
- Yeah.
- And I remember somehow in freshers week,
even though I did introduce
myself to a lot of people within
that short timeframe, probably
more than I have in my life
in that like one week or two
period, three people thought my
name was God when I first
introduced myself (laughs)
- No, why?
- It just like blew my mind.
- I just love it when people
just absolutely butcher my name
in ways that I just wasn't expecting.
I think that is like
my favorite thing ever.
Now that I am like this
public figure where even
my full name is public now.
Like, oh my God.
There hasn't been a single
person who's pronounced my
surname correct.
- Really?
- It's the first time.
- Bizinger
- Yeah.
It's Bizinger, right.
But like my favorite was
the FCCJ panel that we did.
I think the guy called me something like,
"And here at the end of the table,
is Joey the Anime Bizinger"
I was like, first of
all, you forgot the man.
Second of all, I did
an interview with you.
- You should be, you should be the Anime.
- Yeah, the Anime, Joey the Anime (laughs)
- Drop the man, drop
the guy, just the Anime,
- The Anime.
- I am Anime.
- You are the Anime.
Not the man, the Anime.
- I think what I loved about
that live stream with FCCJ is
when he was introducing my name.
And I remember he like introduced you.
He introduced Connor.
And then, I think he got to me.
And I could see the fucking
word processing in his mind.
And there was like this brief
pause before he said my name.
And I remember like the chat
going, he's gonna say, Grant.
He's gonna mispronounce it.
And I remember, it was
just like a slight pause.
But that felt like an hour.
That felt like an entire death note scene.
That fucking pause, man.
- You could've edited in like
the AOL loading sound like-
- (mumbles) One second, three seconds.
- Has anyone ever mispronounced
CDawg or gotten your
internet handle wrong?
- No, CDawg-
- Well, your surname
is pretty difficult to pronounce.
- Yeah, my surname,
but I dunno-
- Also CDawg is very easy as well.
- Yeah. CDawg, I'm
really glad I chose that.
I mean, we said this before, right?
- Smart, It's an easy smart-
- Unintentionally.
I chose it to sound cool.
- Yeah.
- Doesn't actually sound that cool.
But now everyone just calls
me Connor I'd say that easy.
- Yeah.
Well that's what I like about
Trash Taste is that now we
just known as Joey, Garnt and Connor yeah.
- I have a request to anyone
watching this who will meet us
in conventions.
I know Grant is a meme and
it doesn't piss me off when
people call me Grant but
please call me Garnt.
Because it will get to a point
where I literally will not
know if you just don't know who I am or
you are a Trash Taste viewer.
So please, at least call me
Garnt the first time before you
start memeing it up.
Otherwise I will generally not know.
If you just are that deep
into the Trash Taste law,
or if you just generally
think my name's Garnt.
- Genuinely won't be able to-
- Likewise with me, Josh is not my name.
- It is
- It is now
- [Joey] John is also not my name it is.
- (Connor mumbles indistinctly)
- If you call him Josh, now
everyone's gonna know that you
watch this episode of Trash Taste.
- Oh, God.
(Garnt laughing)
How come I'm not allowed to
get away with it, but you are,
what the fuck?
- Yeah, Garnt's like, don't do this to me,
but do it to Joey, he'll be fine.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
Don't do it to me.
- Don't do the exact same thing
- As long as it's not to me.
- Bully Joey, just don't
bully me. I'm begging you.
- I can't believe it.
- So people just spell my
name incorrectly that's all.
They don't say it wrong.
- Well, I mean, there's only so many ways
you can fucking pronounce Connor.
- Yeah. Oh, it's all 'con air' maybe.
- [Joey] 'con air'.
- 'con-air'
- I think that's a movie-
- My favorite movie
- Yeah I think that's in a movie.
- Great movie.
- My favorite Nicholas Cage movie.
- It's an honor to be
confused with "Con Air"
- Fantastic.
(Garnt laughing)
- That sounds like the cursive Conner
- [Joey] Conner.
- Just like if Sebastian
pronounces could be as Conner.
(Connor laughing)
- Maybe.
- That's what you should be like.
If someone at a convention
stops you being like,
"Hey Sebastian" they should
be like, "It's Con Air"
- I never saw in my
life until like I got on
the internet that you could
spell Connor with an E-R.
- [Joey] Conner.
- Conner.
- C-O-N-N-E-R
I never saw that but a
friend of my school who was
called Connah, but it
was spelled C-O-N-N-A-H.
- Connah
- There-
- What's the Australian-
- 'Cause there was also a place near me
that was called Connor something.
- Right.
But lemme spell that one-
- That is like a very phonetic
Connor isn't it Connah.
- Connah
- It's Connah Mate.
- Yeah, Connah.
- It was interesting.
'cause I was like, am I the weird?
No, I've got the normal.
I have the normal.
- Yeah, yours is the normal one.
- I have the normal
Connor, I'm pretty sure
I am the real one.
This is all a joke. You're all lying.
None of you are the real Connor.
- Who's the person who had the
weirdest name that you knew
personally in your life?
- What do you judge as weird?
- Okay
- Like obscure or just like,
why would you choose that?
- Okay, for me I knew a guy
in my school whose first name,
whose real name was Gameron
- Gameron
- Yeah.
Not Cameron, Gameron with a G.
- I kind of like that.
- That sounds cool.
- I thought was fucking cool.
- But it's just like,
in my head, I was like, first of all,
where does that come from?
And second of all was like
their parents' handwriting
so shit at the birth certificate
that the doctor was like,
"Oh, that's an interesting,
way to spell Cameron."
- There was a kid from another school.
I always was so jealous.
They'd called that kid, Zeus.
- Zeus?
- That was his first name.
- Fuck you, dude.
- And I was like-
- God.
And I was like, again, the
fun with really badass names
is that if you don't
live up to a badass name,
it looks pathetic.
Like imagine like you're like
a kind of super shy person
- Yeah
- You're like, what's your name?
"Oh, it's Zeus"
you need to be larger than life
if you're called Zeus, right?
- That's like in school when
you had that one surname,
I knew a guy whose surname was Champion.
- Oh.
- And unfortunately-
- Was he a champion?
- Unfortunately no.
- Wow.
- He didn't quite live up to his surname.
- It was a surname though.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause if it was your first
name everyone's calling you...
- Oh, right. Exactly.
- The parents must have been confident.
They'd be like, you better
live up to this name
or you're a failure.
- You are a literal champion.
- They must have gone to like
the sperm bank got the
highest grade sperm.
They're like nine foot guy,
went to Harvard, 10,000 IQ.
They're like this guy's
a Zeus from a 100%.
- Was it actually spelled like the god?
Yeah.
- Exact same way.
- Oh my God, that's so badass.
- And I remember 'cause I
threw javelin against him
and I beat him and I was
like, I beat the Zeus javelin.
- [Joey] That's so ironic.
- I was like, this is amazing.
I was like, this is great. I beat Zeus.
At the time I didn't care though.
But now I'm like, I beat Zeus at javelin.
It's not a big deal.
- No biggie.
- It's not a big deal, but it is
- Yeah, one of my mates who
used to live here in Japan,
Australian guy, his real
full name was Storm Angus.
- That is the most Australian
name I've ever heard.
- That is the most badass...
When he introduced himself as that,
I was like, no, you're not.
- That's just an
Australian superhero name.
(all laughing)
- Look it's Storm Angus.
- Ah, yeah-
(Joey shrieking)
- Sounds like a superhero
- He just shoots down
lightning (shrieking)
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- He just throws down
like fosters or something.
( Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Oh, my God.
- Love you Storm.
Oh my God.
- That's why I want go to Australia, man.
I've never been to Australia.
I just really want to go.
Sounds like a laugh.
- Oh yeah,
- It's all right.
Australia's that one
place where you're like,
I can't believe people like this exist.
- [Garnt] Yeah
- Like unironically,
- I've always wondered what are
Australian conventions like?
- Okay. I mean there isn't really a lot.
I've been to two different ones.
There is Supernova which
is more like a Comic Con.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And then there is SMASH,
which is the big Anime Con
in Sydney.
- Right
The SMASH stand for anything?
- Yeah. The Sydney Manga Anime Show.
- Good name.
- Okay, yeah.
- So the first time I
went was in like 2013, '14
something like that.
And there was maybe like
3000 people, 4,000 people.
It was tiny convention.
But the year that I went
before the pandemic where I was
a guest at there was like
almost like 30, 40,000 people.
So it's like clearly grown massively.
I honestly think like in
terms of like the actual,
like vibe of the Con and stuff like that,
I don't really see it as that
much different to like a U.S
Con or any other like
English-speaking convention,
because it's like everyone-
- Can speak-
- Yeah. I actually can't spell the word-
- Not actual cuts, but yeah.
So we're not throwing Cons.
- But like Australian Cons
- Yeah.
Obviously I felt a little
more at home because
I was talking to people
with the same accent as me.
- Yeah.
- Because like that was like
my first Con ever, right.
It's like my home tuff, but yeah,
In terms of like a Con experience,
I didn't really see it as that
much more different to like a
standard American Con I guess.
I feel just like weebs in general
or like Anime fans in general,
they kind of all give
off like the same vibe.
A lot of them are just kind of
like chill and down to earth
and just wanna like chat with you.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause like in Australia, a
lot like America where is like
a lot of stranger friendliness
is still pretty prevalent,
right?
- Yeah.
- So a lot of people didn't
really have problems,
coming up to me and talking
to me and stuff like that just
as like, Hey, Joey what's up man?
that kind of stuff.
I mean you guys will definitely
have a fucking great time
if we ever end up going to SMASH
or an Australian convention,
every now and then you
will meet those like very
stereotypical, loud Aussies who,
(mumbles indistinctly) that level, right?
- But-
- That sounds good to me.
- That sounds like a laugh.
- Yeah.
I feel though, those kinds of people,
you wouldn't really find in
a lot of like Anime Cons,
you'll see them at the pub.
- Right.
- But you know, very rarely
have I seen an Anime fan
- Those conventions you
love going to the pub after,
that's close by you just see like Curito
downing like a Stellar.
You're like what's going on?
I don't remember this part.
- It's like, you know, chicken,
like in an Alcohol Cosplay,
like doing a shoey it's like that.
- You like to drink with us (mumbles)
- I unfortunately didn't
see that, I wish I did
- Do a lot of people get
drunk at Aussie conventions?
'cause that's the big thing
about British conventions,
way more than like-
- So much.
It is like-
- all they do.
- It's more than the
actual convention itself.
It's just people are just
like, oh, there's Anime here.
Cool, Let's get a fucking pint.
- It's hard to say at least in Sydney,
I don't think it's would be
as much as in the UK just
because like drinking or
eating out in Sydney is really
fucking expensive.
Like a pint of beer is
like fucking $10 Australian
and like a lot of like
places in Sydney, right?
Like in the city.
- 10 Aussie dollars or-
- 10 Real dollars,
$10 is real currency show.
- $10 Reduced.
So I think to like a lot
of kids who come to these
conventions like $10 is a lot of money.
That's $10 you could spend
on Anime Merge at the Con.
- Yeah, of course.
- So I didn't see as many
drunk people as I thought there
was gonna be.
But a lot of the parents were
getting drunk that's for sure.
(all laughing)
They were like they've had a hard day.
- They probably drove like
an hour to get into the city
and be like hey kids have fun
at your Japanese convention.
Daddy and I are gonna go over to the pub
and get shitfaced while we wait for you.
- Yeah
So like-
- I've taken care of the kids.
- Yeah, so like in between
like signings and stuff,
I'd take a step outside and
you look over at the terrace
of some of these like pubs,
on the water and there's just
a lot of parents clearly just
like waiting for their kids,
just being like (mumbles) yeah?
- I can't blame them.
- Honestly. I'd probably do
the same when I have kids,
'cause I'm like an only child,
so I never had this experience,
but I remember like Sydney
talking about it all the time
where your parents would
just take you to events
and then you would just
give all the responsibility
to the older sibling to take
care of the younger siblings.
And just like, here's a
bunch of money fuck off.
- Yeah.
Have fun, you know?
- I definitely have that. That's for sure.
- Maybe I can't remember really
maybe I was a little shy.
- I think I've very rarely
had experiences like that.
'Cause I think like me
and my sister didn't really
like share a lot of like
the same like interests
when we were growing up.
I feel as adults now, we are
like starting to like share
more of like the same likes on things.
I don't really like remember going
to a lot of events with my sister.
Maybe we went to like a
few concerts, but that's-
- Did your parents ever take
you to an event that you just
didn't wanna fucking go to?
But you had to go to 'cause
your parents were going to.
- Yeah.
- Football matches.
- Football matches (giggles)
- My dad used to drag
me to football matches.
He's gonna love this bit now.
He's like, "I didn't drag
you, you wanted to go?"
No, he would bribe me with chocolate.
He would be like, I'll
buy you like a Galaxy bar,
which is like this chocolate in the UK.
Not like the small bars.
- Yeah (laughs)
- Like this sized block one,
it's like, we got some serious
chocolate Malach here.
He's like I'll buy it for you.
And then the worst part my
dad would laugh at this.
When I was like eight, he would
take me to like pub before
- Yeah.
- Right.
- Where it was literally
like a football club, right?
- Yeah.
- So it's cheap. It's dirty.
It's absolutely rammed. It stinks.
It's like everyone is eating
like pork scratchings and
downing like really cheap pints.
- Yeah -
- Right.
- I actually remember just
sitting there just like not
understanding anything although
that they would just ask me
sometimes stuff about football
and I'd be like, yeah.
Wayne Rooney.
- Yeah.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I just remember I never
understood anything.
- Right.
- And one time I went
to a match and Everton,
my dad's obsessed with like
Everton family and stuff.
And I remember they'd
won because I was there
and my dad was like convinced
that I was the good luck charm.
- Yeah.
- So I got dragged to more,
I told him, I hate it.
I do not want to go.
I absolutely despise this
'cause I would just stand there.
And I remember it was
cold and it was so loud
and I just wanted to play my Game Boy.
- Yeah.
- But I had to watch these people kick
and I was like, why is it 90 minutes long?
That's so long.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- So yeah.
To a child, 90 minutes is long.
- Yeah. And I would always be
like, can I get some like...
'cause I don't know why as
a kid, I just wanted to eat.
- Oh yeah.
- I just wanted to eat.
And they would sell those
like stupidly long hot dogs
at these football events.
- Yeah.
- I remember one time I had
one and my dad let me like,
just like hold onto it for
like two seconds and someone
bumped into me and I dropped it.
- Right.
And then I was so mortified.
And I remember, I think
that ruined football for me.
I was like, no, I'm done.
- I can't even eat a hotdog in peace
- This guy didn't even buy me a new one.
He like knocked me over.
And I was like, what the fuck?
- Yeah.
But I was like eight, I
dunno how to articulate.
All I remember was I was just
really sad that I dropped this
hot dog.
- Right.
- And you couldn't buy a new one
- So my dad had just given me
like enough money to buy it.
And it was like he'd like, let me have it.
And then all the other food
was like steak kidney pies from
this thing called Pukka Pies in the UK.
That's was so bad, really bad. Right.
I remember I sorta liked it,
but just remember being like
totally confused and not really
understanding it.
And I never really liked football.
- Yeah.
- My brothers did though.
They liked going.
And my older brother liked it a lot,
but I just never liked it.
And I felt like I was a failure to my dad
'cause he was like, I just
want you to like sports.
Why can't you like sports?
- Like be a normal person and like-
- Football
I'm like the only kid in the
UK that didn't like football.
I was like, why?
- I remember 'cause my parents
were like really into like
looking at property, right?
- Like what?
(Garnt laughing)
- And for the longest time I was like,
are we gonna move house?
I would get excited
It's like, no, we're just looking?
- What?
- And I was like, we're
literally window shopping houses.
And they're like, yeah.
And I was like two to like a 10 year old.
I was like, what the fuck?
- Like the most non privileged
thing I've ever heard.
- Well, because my dad
is heavily into stocks
and investing.
- He's investment.
- He's an investor.
- I'm watching a home in the sun
because it's for investment.
- Yeah.
He was an investor, right?
And also like my parents
used to go a lot as well
so that they could get inspirations
for like interior design
and stuff like that because
my dad loved doing renovations
into the house and stuff.
So he would get a lot of like
good ideas from that, right?
- [Connor] That makes more sense.
- Yeah. But to a 10 year old,
I don't know what the fuck
like all that shit is.
You would think if your parents
came up to you and said,
"Son, we're gonna go check
out some houses today."
The first thing you would
think of as a 10 year old is,
Yay, we're moving.
And my sister who's three
years younger than me
was like we're moving houses,
that's so exciting, yay!
So really for the first couple of times,
we'd go along with them.
Until we realized, we're not moving,
- we're just looking at houses
- Just looking at them.
- I have a question,
actually, this just came out.
You can't answer it Garnt unfortunately.
It's about brothers and sisters.
- Okay.
- So obviously let's
say there's two siblings
or three siblings in my house.
How was it decided, who gets
which bedroom in your house?
- That's a good question.
Well.
- Did you ever ask.
- "Mad Royale Squid Game"
- 'Cause I am the middle son.
And I got the tiniest room.
- Ah, okay.
Well, I think for us, we
got lucky because the house
that I grew up in or I was
born in was like bought
just at the same time
as they got that house.
So I basically got first dips.
Because my sister wasn't born yet.
- Oh, so you got to choose?
- I wasn't like a three
year old being like,
Father, this room is a little
larger than the other one.
- Well, you know, what's funny.
That's exactly what my
parents fucking did.
- Really?
- They asked me when I
was like two or whatever,
which room I wanted.
- Gosh, when you were two,
- I don't know at an age
where I cannot comprehend what I am doing.
- It's a big space either way for a kid.
- Yeah. I'm like, this is fine.
This is great.
I think I literally chose like
the Harry Potter closet and
I'm like Mom don't fucking
believe what two or
three-year old Connor choose.
Why would you do that?
- Mom comes out with a
contractor. Is this you,
this your name?
- I've got the receipt.
- Did you sign this?
- You signed by blood.
- Did you sign this? I'm.
- Like, what the fuck is this?
I would never choose it.
You know, I would've never chosen.
- I got the room, which was
right next to my parents' room
because obviously I
was the firstborn child
- And then my sister, got the lost room.
- Which just so happened
to be next to the toilet.
- Right.
- I remember she would complain
because I think our rooms
were pretty much the same size.
Like it might have been minor differences,
but it didn't really matter.
It was roughly the same size.
But I remember my sister
used to complain being like,
at least you're not fucking
in a room where every time
someone wanna take a shit
in the middle of the night,
you get woken up by it.
And that sounds like you problem
- But also you're closest to the toilet.
- That's that's what I said.
That's an advantage.
That's a perk.
- I'm wondering comments.
If you have brothers and
sisters or what, whatever,
how was it decided which
room was given to who
- Can't relate
- or you were all shoved into one room?
- Can't relate.
- Well actually, yeah.
When we were really
little, my sister and I
obviously just slept in the
same room, in the same bed.
And then it was probably
maybe when I was six or seven
that I finally got to
pick one of the rooms,
I don't remember there being
like a ritualistic "Squid Game"
of like, well now fight to the death.
- It was just, apparently I
chose this room, which is-
- You remember choosing the room?
- No, of course not.
I don't. I remember I'd
asked my parents later on.
I was like, well, I chose it.
I'm like, why would you listen to me?
Why? I am not in the right mind.
I cannot make good decisions.
- Yeah.
- It was probably massive
to you when you chose it,
- It was tiny.
There was no place to put
more than like a single bed.
Not that I would ever need
more than a single bed.
- Like even if I wanted bigger,
there was actually no
space to put it anywhere.
- Yeah.
- And so it was just like-
- Of course you talking about that, right?
Like you obviously remember
it different to your parents.
So I guarantee your parents are
gonna remember it and recall
all are differently being like,
Oh, I specifically remember Connor fucking
volunteering his tribute.
Yes, I will take the
smallest room for the family.
- Yeah.
- Going back to like
weird events your parents
are taking you to.
The thing that sticks out
to my mind right now is my
parents or my Mom once took
me to a meditation meetup.
I think it was a meditation meetup.
- Okay.
- So my Mom's like Buddhist.
This was before I became
like a monk or a kid monk or
anything like that.
Sometimes you pray or you
meditate for good karma
and all that stuff.
So sometimes when Mom
would go to like these,
Buddhist meetups or these
meditation meets up.
What you do at this meetup is
you go there and you meditate
for about an hour in like darkness.
- Okay.
- With a bunch of other people or like?
- With a bunch of other people.
- I was about seven years
old when this happened.
I think like at time there
was no one to take care
at home or something.
I don't know why.
But my Mom's like,
"Garnt you're coming with
me, we're gonna meditate"
I remember her framing it in
a way where we're just gonna
meditate for a little
bit, like five minutes.
That's what it was in my head.
I didn't know how long,
I would be sitting still
for at this meet up.
She taught me how to
meditate and we'd do it for
like 10 to like 15 minutes at most.
That's what I thought I was
getting into. So we get there.
I remember the head guy was just like,
"Hey, thank you all for coming.
So we're gonna be sitting here.
I'm gonna hit the gong and
we're gonna turn off lights
and we're gonna just sit here for an hour.
And after the hours on, I'm
gonna hit the gong again."
- "Squid Game"
After you turn the lights off,
half people are dead there.
- And so I remember
thinking, what the fuck?
I've got to sit here
in silence for an hour.
What? I was seven years old.
I couldn't like sit still for
five minutes let alone a hour.
- Like solving the God equation.
So I remember sitting down,
I'm like fucking panicking.
Trying to figure out.
How the fuck I am going
to sit here for an hour.
I look over to my Mom.
My Mom's just like already
like in the zone. - Yeah.
- She's already gone
- She's long gone.
- She's in another fucking
dimension right now.
And so he hits the gong.
Luckily they have a clock in
the room so you can see how
much time goes past.
Now what you're meant to do
during meditation is like,
you are meant to just
clear your mind, right?
The point of an hour is that
it shouldn't feel like an hour
because to your minds, it
should be as empty as possible.
So you shouldn't really feel
the passage of time or you
should feel it less than usual. Right?
That's the entire like "zone"
you're supposed to get with meditation.
So I remember thinking, all
right Garnt, you got this,
you've meditated for 15 minutes.
You can do an hour.
And I remember sitting there and to me,
I think about 40 minutes has past,
let me sneak over at the clock.
I look over five minutes has gone by.
I'm just like, oh, I
start fucking sweating.
I look around-
- How are you seeing the
clock in the dark? - Huh?
- It was like one of the
glow in the dark - Oh, Okay.
- With like luminescence.
- That makes it even harder
not to look as a kid.
- Yeah.
- I wanna look at the glow.
- So I come up with
this five head strategy.
Because at that point I
was obsessed with "Pokemon"
- Who wasn't?
- Yeah. Who wasn't?
I remember like back in the
day I had like recorded like an
entire season of Pokemon
and that was like my only entertainment.
So I had like watched this VHS
on this recording of "Pokemon"
like fucking 10, 20 times.
- Like you should
So I think to myself, how am I
going to get through an hour?
I got a five head idea.
What if I just watched three
episodes of Pokemon in my mind?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
And if I watched three episodes
of Pokemon in my mind an
hour went up fast.
- So I remember this-
- This fucking serially experiments lane.
- So I like escape. It's
either casual in my mind.
- Is this the metaverse?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Like entered the metaverse in my mind.
And I just start watching,
I just start playing
the episodes of Pokemon
that I can remember.
Unfortunately, I think
some gaps were missed off
because I remember like
watching in my mind.
- Yeah.
- Three episodes looking at the clock
and half an hour had gone by.
Maybe time moves differently in my mind
- Garnt got a gold sprint
on for watching "Pokemon"
- So I think I watched an
entire season of "Pokemon"
in my mind.
- Your mind was just like, all right.
- Cutting out all the filler right now.
Only the important information.
- I think I got through
an entire fucking season.
And then I finally hear the
gong and I'm like thank fuck.
And I remember afterwards
some of my Mom's friends comes
over to her and be like,
I'm like so impressed with your son.
Like, how do you sit there for an hour?
Like my son can't concentrate
anything for five minutes.
I'm so impressed with your son.
And I'm just like, they dunno.
I just watched "Pokemon" one for an hour.
- Meanwhile you are drenching in sweat.
- What does Ash say again in this episode,
- No, Ash was about to get
into the indigo league.
At least you stopped at a
fucking good point, man.
- How the fuck did you
do that? That's insane.
- This man literally opened
up his third eye by reciting
"Pokemon" in his head.
- Anime companies hate this one
trick to letting you rewatch
the Anime in your mind.
- You wanna recite "Pokemon"?
- That's the real secret to
like reaching in Lightman.
You don't empty your mind.
You just watch one piece in
your mind and you just reach
enlightenment
- Could you do that now?
- I could not do that now.
- I could watch a show and then
couldn't do that immediately after.
- Because that was back in
the day when you were a kid
and you had like that one thing
that you watched overnight.
- Yeah
- You could just like recite it.
I remember I could probably
like recite the entire movie of
"Toy Story" or something in my mind,
just because like I
watched it so many times.
- Damn
- There are some movies like that too.
I could probably recite the
entirety of "Pulp Fiction"
it's 'cause I've seen it so
many fucking times right now,
three and a half hour movie, let's go
- What you need to better
meditate for that long?
- Yeah, when I need to meditate
I'm just like-
- [Connor] So what again?
So what again
- I dare you, I double
dare you motherfucker?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- You know what they call quarter pounder
with cheese in France?
(all laughing)
- But Connor did you
never have that as a kid?
Just like some, a game or
something that you played
so many times that you could
just like recite it for memory?
- No
- Never.
- Not recite here. I'd
probably played SAFA Bunch,
but never seen I had
to recite from memory.
- But are you the kind
of person who remembers
song lyrics easily?
- Not, not at all.
- [Joey] Okay.
- I actually cannot remember
song lyrics without looking at
the sheet.
- [Joey] Right.
- And even then it's like,
it'll last like a day.
- Yeah, because it's really interesting.
There's two types of
people where there's like,
there's ones who are like,
you can listen to a song
once and you just like
miraculously just remember
how the lyrics go.
And then there are
people who are just like,
I could listen to this song
50 times and it's like,
I'll recognize the lyrics
if someone tells me,
but I can't recite.
- Okay.
So I had this realization
the other day because I've
obviously given Connor
a lot of shit for like
hearing the beeps and the boops.
- Yeah.
- And then I just had this
realization that I think I listen
to music like beeps and
beeps as well, right?
Lyrics mean nothing to me.
It's so weird.
- Yeah.
- Where I listen to a song
and if lyrics aren't there
I feel like something's missing.
'Cause I do think lyrics
need is a part of the song.
But to me, lyrics are almost
like another instrument to me.
It's so weird.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah
- Where I don't listen
to what they're saying.
You can take a song that I
love and you lay the lyrics out
in front of me and I'm just like,
I've never heard this song in my life.
(Joey laughing)
What is the song?
- Well I would argue that best
artists and the best singers
and the best bands, as you
said, use their voice as an
instrument.
But then if you want to
read into the lyrics,
the lyrics are also profound.
where unfortunately, very
few artists can do that.
Where it's either you concentrate fully on
the lyrics to be like, here's
a deep, poetic meaning behind.
- If I'm understanding this, you're saying
the voice is a part of the song.
Is that what you're saying?
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
- Well, yeah, no shit.
- But there are a lot of
artists who don't see it
that way and it also depends
on how the song's mixed.
But like some artists you
hear and it's just like, oh,
I wish I could hear the
instruments because it's just being
drowned out by the singing.
- I don't know
- Have you ever properly
listened to the lyrics of
a song and it's changed the
way you think about a song
because you properly
actually read into it.
- Yeah like the new Weekend
album's really good.
But if you just actually
listen to what he's saying,
it's depressing as fuck.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- So that rarely ever-
- You're like vibing.
You're like, dude, this song is so good.
And he's like,
♪ I'm fucking depressed ♪
and shit is going wrong.
And it's like, yeah, fuck this is so good.
- [Joey] Wait, what'd you say?
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
- You like listening and
it's like, wait, hold on.
Yeah. He de... what?
- Yeah. I can't even get to that moment.
'Cause it's really weird.
But like sometimes if there's
like a disconnect between how
the song makes me feel versus
what the lyrics are saying,
I always like go towards
what the song makes me feel.
- Same
- And it's so weird
because I dunno how much
of this is bullshit.
- Welcome to the beeps and boops day.
- Yeah. That's it.
I hear the beeps and the boops.
The beeps and the boobs
make me feel something.
And that's what I feel towards
a song that I hardly ever
listen to lyrics at all,
because it never changes
how I feel towards the song.
It's so weird.
- I just-
- You guys are literally that
type of people who would make
a fucking art Buzzfeed article
being like top 10 songs that
have a dark meaning.
- [Connor] We're engineers.
- And be like, did you know?
- I hear the fucking music it
comes in and it just comes in
like a fucking graph in my head.
It comes in like-
- [Joey] The thing is, I get
that. I totally get that.
- But I feel it I do
have emotions towards it.
- [Joey] Yeah. Of course.
- But I don't give a shit
what he's talking about.
- Right.
- I'm just in taking the noise.
And the noise either makes me
feel something or it doesn't.
- Yeah.
Which is why I think for a lot
of songs where there is like
a stark contrast between how
the song makes you feel versus
how the lyrics make you feel.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Is like a big whiplash
for people like you guys
oh, what the fuck?.
- Preface live.
It is different though.
Definitely there's a lot more
to it when its a recorded
album.
- Yeah, of course.
- I feel like that's why I
find it so easy to listen to
a lot of Japanese music
or a lot of like music in
a language that I don't understand.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because I have no idea what
the lyrics they are spitting
most of the time, but you
know, part of me is like,
I feel the emotions hard.
- But this goes had
- I feel the emotion that
they're singing right now.
- [Joey] Oh yeah. Definitely.
- I kind get it, even though
I probably don't get it.
I feel like I get it.
- I can tell you I take
90% of Anime openings.
The lyrics are depressing as fuck.
But just weaves that are
kind of like (mumbles)
- Which I find it's cool.
That's what I find really
interesting though about people
who can do that
- Yeah.
- It's the reason why I
feel that in and of itself,
that discovery of when people
find out this really bright
and colorful and very
positive sounding song
actually has a really
fucking dark meaning.
And it's that realization
of like, oh, shit
I just got played because I
wasn't listening to the lyrics.
- That's why 'cause we like
had this idea to do a music
three by three, for like ages
and I've like low key actually
been shitting myself at the-
- [Joey] Why?
- Because one of the mediums
I find hardest to fucking explain
- Is music
Because I literally hear this song-
- [Joey] This sounds good
- This song made me feel things.
I just really like it.
And people are like oh,
did you know the meaning of that song?
I have no idea of the
meaning of that song.
- Yeah.
- But it made me feel things.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It make me feel things.
- [Joey] I get that.
- Welcome to the beeps and
the boops ladies and gentlemen
- I thought you were in my team.
I feel betrayed.
- Welcome to the beeps and boops.
- I feel absolutely betrayed goddamnit
- The music episode would be
Joey talking with you out.
- Yeah.
- And then me and Garnt
go, I like this one.
- Yeah
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- That why I almost don't want to do it.
'Cause I think I'd
rather just make a video.
- You carry the episode.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Which might be the shortest Trash Taste
episode of all time.
- Yeah, probably
- Like 40 minutes in and
we're like, and that's it?
Yeah. All right. Thanks
for joining Trash Taste
- Do you have an example
of like a song where
you found more like
reading into the lyrics
and the deeper meaning of
that song, as opposed to just
listening to the initial
beats, the beeps and boops.
- I'll go into like-
- Pink Floyd, The wall.
- Well, yes, that too.
I think there's a lot of like
artists that, you know...
it's that brilliance of using
the lead singer as just like
an instrument it where it's like,
if you're not listening to the
lyrics or anything like that,
it still sounds great.
And it's still like sticky in your head.
- Yeah.
- But then one day you're like,
I've listened to this song
like three or four times,
but I've never actually read the lyrics,
let me read into the lyrics
and then you read into it
and a lot of it's very
like poetic and you know,
completely changes the
way you view that song.
Like Turning Japanese, you know that song?
- Yeah
- No
♪Turning Japanese ♪
♪I think I'm turning... ♪
(mimicking the song beat)
- You don't know that song?
- [Garnt] Yeah, I know that song.
- That song's about masturbation.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
But no one knows it because
no one reads into the lyrics.
They just hear the
(mimicking the song beat)
and I was like, oh yeah, love that song.
- Is that what Turning Japanese is about?
- Yeah.
- It's about masturbation.
- I've never heard of this song.
- Well like how Pumped Up
Kicks is about school shootings
- [Connor] I know that one.
- Like when people first
discovered that they were like,
oh my God, I've been fucking gebaited.
- It's catchy as shit.
- It's catchy as fuck.
It's a jam of a song
I find that to be like...
As someone who also writes
music that is so much fucking
harder than it looks.
- Yeah. No, I can imagine.
And I feel bad that I don't,
or I have the inability to
appreciate it because like, but-
- But I feel that's fine because,
I feel with those kinds of songs
they're taking into account
how it sounds first,
and then they think about
the meaning afterwards.
- Yeah.
I think the only exception
is with rap music,
where it is just like
basically just lyrical poems
to a beat.
So that's where I actually have
more of an understanding or
like an image in my head of, oh man,
these lyrics go fucking hard so-
- I do listen to the lyrics
of rap, try to, at least.
It's hard though.
- But like most of the times
I actually see the lyrics
sheets and it almost
transforms it that to a point
where I don't even
recognize the song anymore.
It was always like separate
from the song itself.
It's so weird.
If someone can explain this to me,
I'm super curious because I
am incapable of like getting
the meaning of lyrics as
I'm listening to the song
at the same time.
- You recognize it has anything
to do with the fact that
I'm the only musical trained
one outta the three of us?
- No, probably pretty appreciate it more.
- Yeah,
- Maybe
- To me it's all noise.
- Right?
- I like it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But it's noise. - I can
play musical instruments,
but I've never been like
professionally trained.
- Right.
- I think that's just what it is.
I feel it's just because
you've been trained to listen
to music in a different way.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- That you can just perceive
these smaller points that other
people would just perceive as
just the beeps and the boops.
- I mean, to me, like-
- It's like people who go to
a gallery and look at art.
- [Garnt] Right.
- A lot of them have just been
trained to look at this thing
in a completely different way
that you otherwise would've
a very hard time grasping.
You go to an art gallery with
an art critic and they'd be
like, yes, I love the flow and
the texture and the feelings
that I get from it.
It's making me feel this way.
And the average person
looking it be like, oh yeah,
I like the color red as well.
I think it's just based
on how you are trained.
- I can play musical
instruments and stuff like that,
but I've never like
studied music theory or
anything like that.
So when I like wrote songs
before it was more like
(mumbles) sound nice
or something like that
Chord sound nice.
That was just like my process.
(Joey indistinctly speaking)
- Musically trained.
- Yeah, musically trained.
- Goddamn.
- But yeah, at this rate,
I don't know if we'll ever
actually end up doing
a music three by three.
- I'm down. I just gotta
think of nine albums
I like right now-
- Are we doing albums or
artists? That's the question.
- we should do artists.
- Artists, okay-
- 'Cause like-
- I think of 4, 5 that I feel
like I could strongly say
I've listened to everything.
I like everything.
A lot of others I'm like
I like this one album.
Like Arctic Monkeys, I like
a lot, but not every album.
- [Joey] Right
- And I get it.
You wanna be experimental to your thing,
but I don't know how I
can sit there and be like,
this is one of my favorite
artists, by the way,
this one album's shit I don't like.
- Well, I think that's a valid-
- I mean like-
- A lot of my favorite artists
have a shit album or two.
- Like, I dunno if I'm a
anomaly in this as well,
but I don't normally listen
to albums as a whole.
- You just listen to a song
- That's very normal.
- I'm like shitting myself,
thinking of nine albums.
'Cause I'm like, how many four
albums have I listened to?
- [Joey] I mean it's just-
- We'll do it eventually.
- Yeah. We'll do it eventually.
- I gotta figure out how to
like talk about music first.
- You guys deal with that.
And then when you guys are ready,
come back and then we can do it.
- I feel like he was trying to
say something with this song.
I could feel it. I don't
know what it was exactly.
But I feel like-
- I like these words.
- In the song he said he
felt it coming many times
and I believe he did feel it coming.
- Oh, I was definitely coming as well.
My God.
- But anyway, that's been this
week's Trash Taste episode
- Oh, My God
What about these patrons though?
Do they listen to lyrics?
- I don't know.
- But they listen to us
on Spotify, right Joey?
- Oh, they definitely do
listen to us on Spotify.
And they also support us on Patreon.
you can do the same as well.
By going over to our Patreon page on
patreon.com/trashtaste also...
What's that?
- They Listen to Trash
Taste, which is all lyrics.
- It's all lyrics.
- Nothing but lyrics.
- I used the instrument as my voice.
- Trash Taste bars.
Nothing but bars for two and a half hours.
But yeah, if you'd like
to support the show,
go our Patreon, also follow us on Twitter,
Send us memes on the Subred.
And if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
But yeah, music three by
three coming eventually.
When these boys are ready.
- When I'm ready to talk about music.
- In the meantime,
thanks for watching guys.
And we'll see you guys next.
(All shouting) Bye!
(soft music)